Queen yourself, Kelly Jean, the the Alog community that has spent
a substantive amount of time kind of, you know, documenting his
behavior recently and in the past. How could I not just use this
to like go after anybody? This is broadly how, you know, Keeles
blamed him for his community hate rating him and stuff, right?
It was just like, oh, based on some vague illusion to a connection,
I'm going to go ahead and say that like whatever we do against
you is justified. I can go and report your YouTube, your Twitch,
whatever. Now it's all justified. So I would say this is very
much, hey, you have to stop what you're doing and I will dox
you and terrorize you and I'm justified in doing that because
you have talked about me. I don't know. It's just like it's one
of those things where it's like, okay, doxing is pretty bad.
Okay, like calling for my death and the death of other people
you've attempted to do, that's also pretty bad. Putting those
things together, I don't really know how you get um I felt like
more people would kind of be outraged about that to tell you
the truth. It's a little offensive. How's life? Oh, pretty good.
How are you? uh been better to tell you the truth, been a little
less uh I had fewer, you know, calls for my death, you know,
at previous points in my life. So, been interesting. How's the
uh how's the doxing reverse docs? How's that thing going? Uh
I don't know. I guess it's we'll see if like anything happens.
I don't know. It's just like it's one of those things where it's
like, okay, doxing's pretty bad. Okay. Like calling for my death
and the death of other people you've attempted to dox. That's
also pretty bad. Putting those things together. I don't really
know how you get um I felt like more people would kind of be
outraged about that to tell you the truth. It's a little offensive.
Well, how many uh just out of curiosity, how many death threats
have you gotten? Me personally, oh, lots of people have done
it like through um Twitter DMs or Discord or chat or whatever.
But it's like um it's not it's like under it's like the I don't
take it seriously when it's like just anonymous accounts like
clearly trying to with you. You know what I'm saying? Like if
you made that account yesterday and you type a message about
like my docs being up somewhere, I'm just like, "Okay, I don't
take you seriously." What? Uh I haven't had like a lot of credible
death threats other than from Destiny. How did you feel about
um his response where he was saying, you know, ba basically like,
"Oh, yeah. Uh Jtock, well, I mean, I don't think he said names,
but you know, he said Jively what I took away from it was Jtock
and Queen play footsie with Kiwi Farm. So it it's cute that they're
pretending that they give a [__] about this when
their parts of their communities are schizophrenic docs or Yeah.
I would just wonder like so he blamed me for getting swatted.
I don't know when he was swatted, but I know at least one of
them was from the Republican the Trump thing, right? So like
I couldn't have possibly been responsible for that. Um I think
the other one was the Muslim thing, but I'm not 100% sure. So
to me, I would wonder why he would bring up doxing or sorry swatting
when that has like very little to do with me. I think broadly
I would ask, you know, if I if I could have asked him a question
there in the moment, I would have just said, "Okay, could you
like walk me through your
Oh, one second. Hold on. Confirmation bias donated J SDLK. Can
you try to put him on Bill Maher's shoulders? Sure. I can try
to put him on Bill Maher's shoulders. I'm putting your head on
Bill Mar's shoulders on my stream. So I would just say like could
you connect some of those dots for me because it seems like overall
like how could I not just use this to like go after anybody?
This is broadly how you know Keels blamed him for his community
hate rating him and stuff, right? It was just like oh based on
some vague illusion to a connection I'm going to go ahead and
say that like whatever we do against you is justified. I can
go and report your YouTube, your Twitch, whatever now it's all
justified, right? And he was pretty vehement about arguing against
that. that like without solid links and without letting the other
person know. Like for example, he said, "Oh, there's like a ton
of he does this all the time and it's just a malicious lie, right?
Where he'll say, "Oh, Jtock has like people who link my revenge
on his discord server or something like that." No revenge has
ever been linked to my server. Uh the Kiwi Farms links are blocked
or uh deleted like there and you get timed out for referencing
KF stuff. So like I just don't understand broadly how he is um
how he makes that claim. Like I guess that rule came in somewhere
somewhere in the middle and like it is mods do have to actively
like do something. Uh he also yeah claimed I actively collaborated
with them or but then again I would just want the proof that
he has that shows the links because like can I do you think I
could sufficiently be blamed or held responsible or have people
like actually try to attack or give consequences to me for things
that are like six degrees removed from me? Like if it's if it's
somebody who like I've once messaged in my Discord who has once
messaged somebody from Kiwi Farms who was once posted in the
thread who was once like maybe posted a reply to somebody who's
docked someone. I like I don't know can I be what do you think
about that connection? Because it seemed like you were pretty
willing to just take that qu that answer and I was like oh I
really wish you asked for something. I think when you're having
these conversations right like I I I think when you're having
these conversations Sorry what's that? Can you hear me? Okay.
Sorry, I I was just saying it's tough in the m moment. I was
agreeing with you. Okay. Yeah. So, the Well, it's it's not just
tough tough in the moment. It's it's a question of, you know,
what what are you trying to achieve, right? So, for me,
uh that this conversation was kind of at least the way that I
pitched it to him and the way that I wanted the conversation
to go was, uh I'm I'm kind of interrogating his, you know, moral
philosophy, the way he perceives the way that he was acting in
2022 and the way that he's acting now. If if I had to be uh honest,
then I would say the I was kind of disappointed that there wasn't
an articulation of a change, right? It was kind of like, well,
back then, I don't even know if he said this. This this might
be me inferring something that he might not have even said, uh,
but he said that like, well, at the time, I acted based off of
my moral system then, so there's no way that I could have like
foreseen the consequences of my behavior.
um therefore I wouldn't change anything. Whereas now, uh this
is me reading into it. Uh I I would try to balance my pleasure-
seeeking behavior more with my like moral obligations. But that's
of course like a very non-specific answer, right? like that that
doesn't really that doesn't really tell me like what are you
copying to that you actuallyed up on versus what did you change
about your perceptions around and pleasure seeking and relationships
that's going to prevent this kind of [__] happening
from the future. Sure. And I don't know if you I don't know if
you put it quite that way. I think that could have been a good
way maybe maybe it didn't I just missed it of like I would expect
this to happen again unless you have changed something philosophically.
Right. Yeah. and and and I I don't think you know I don't think
in the conversation I I like pressed him to be like no you must
you must tell me what you have changed tell me what you have
changed now like that obviously didn't happen
um but you know that that that's also kind of the a a non-answer
is also an answer right so if he's if he's avoiding specifically
saying what he's changed then he might not have interrogated
his moral system that much since this incident which would be
uh you you know, problematic because that would basically mean
that there isn't much preventing it from happening in the future.
Sure. So, I guess there's probably two different directions we
could go with like this conversation. Um, I would wonder I guess
I to me I'm kind of wondering why the 2025 behavior wouldn't
be more concerning to you than it seems to be cuz I think that
is like actually just sort of like calculated over time. Hey,
I'm I'm saying I'm like asking for these guys' docs and then
I'm trying to publish docs that I'm saying are them like a month
later. Like it seems like that's like he announces he wants them
and to publish them to harass these people and then he publishes
the docs like 3 weeks or a month later that he purports to be
the docs and then he goes on to call for the death of these people
and then he goes on to justify multiple times on his YouTube
channel calling for the death of these people myself and Queen
specifically. Yeah, I I have to I have to think about what what
I believe is sincere versus what I believe is an excuse, I guess.
And and what I mean by that, so uh if I can articulate Steven's
arguments as best I can, and you can correct me if you heard
something different. So Ste Steven's argument, and and I I'm
not saying it's correct. I'm saying what he said uh is that
uh Queman and yourself I'm just going to use names because I'm
presuming you know that he's talking about Queen and yourself.
Um Queen yourself, Kelly Jean, the the Alog community that has
spent a substantive amount of time kind of, you know, documenting
his behavior recently and in the past, uh that they play fast
and loose and cutesy with more nefarious organizations. when
he's talking about more nefarious organizations, I'm ass I'm
straight up assuming that he's talking about like Kiwi Farms
and Doc and that when you're, you know, when when we're having
this conversation now where you're like, well, what did I specifically
do? In my opinion, he's saying that you're like playing koi and
cute because your your connections with these communities are
more strong than you're letting on. I I don't know the truth
of that
now. I I don't even know if I care to interrogate it. It wouldn't
that be like absolutely wouldn't that be the most important thing
to interrogate? Why? Because it's what it's all predicated on.
Um like literally he's giving you an excuse that he can provide
no evidence for and I would just be hesitant to take somebody's
word for something when they have just maliciously lied against
like about a bunch of people involved in these scenarios. Right.
Yeah. But I don't know. Can I just give you example? Like you
work for PV. You saw him publish that Wicked Supreme had an illicit
relationship with Pixie when he was her supervisor at PV, right?
Yeah. So, like I probably if somebody just is maliciously in
this scenario, I feel like I would have in my opinion I don't
know how that relationship would be elicit. Uh that it would
have been a I guess an age gap of some kind and then a supervisor
and a an employee. He was trying to imply that it was weird that
like Supreme was way older, way more power scenario. Just being
real. Um because I was saying earlier like we have to interrogate,
you know, what's real versus what's not. I don't believe him
that he's upset about that. I I I think that what happened was
I I I think what happened was Wicked Supreme was talking he wanted
something to throw back at him and then he just picked the closest
thing that he could to some kind of you know some kind of uh
what what do you what do you call it? Impugn like where you impug
somebody's character. Uh he he tried to find the closest thing
that he could in order to impugn Wicked Supreme's character.
He just threw it at the wall even though I very much doubt he
cared about it at all. So, in order to get back at Wicked Supreme,
he made up a malicious lie about him to try to malign him to
his community. And I'm just curious why not what what what part
of it is a lie? Um, I think that they dated while Peavey was
going on. I think that he's that much older than her. I think
that he was ever her supervisor. I think every element of the
thing he said was a malicious lie that Arodite and the leader
of Pavey both corroborated and said was a clear malicious lie.
What? What do you mean the leader of Pave and Kyla corroborated
that it was a lie? Uh Kyla posted on Twitter, "This is obviously
a lie. This is obviously not true." And then somebody who was
high up in PV, I can't remember if it was um I can't remember
if it was Sam or not. Somebody I I don't think it was Sam, I
think it was somebody else, corroborated that. Yeah, this is
just a lie. This is like not true. He was not her supervisor.
Um yeah, so every single element except the fact that they had
a relationship in the past was a malicious lie. Well, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So, so I don't I I don't want to legal ease it. Um, and
by legal it I just mean like uh I the the thing that he's trying
to point to, you know, in my opinion. Well, well, hold on. Let's
see if we can skip ahead to like the solution. We can both agree
that he probably doesn't care about a fratern like a what do
you call that? Like a conflict of interest relationship. He probably
doesn't care about that. He probably doesn't care about the age
gap. He probably doesn't care about whether or not he was a supervisor.
Right. It all all that was happening was one of his friends was
talking or one of his former friends was talking about him. He
felt hurt and he was lashing out, right? Yeah. The talking [__]
by the way, was saying like, "Oh, I used to watch Bill Cosby,
then I watched Louis CK, and then I found Destiny. What am I
doing to these people?" That's like the talking [__]
that he decided to make this malicious layup that involved one
of his victims. Okay. One of the people he I guess so again,
like that's kind of the thing where Well, actually, this is kind
of what I was going to get at is
um I don't know if you're expecting me to like defend him. I
I I don't I don't think I will be defending him. I I think I'll
just be, you know, kind of like uh articulating what I understand
under the situation as best I can. Sure. So, I guess what I would
expect is probably some demonstration or basically just saying
that you have figured out that you actually don't hold the values
you previously stated. So, previously you'd said you totally
distance yourself from somebody who had done doxing or anything
like adjacent to doxing because that's like probably the worst
thing you can do, right? And that Mr.
convo that happened I think 2 or 3 years ago and then I think
you said in a conversation with Lav and Queen around the time
this started that you would need to see contrition on Destiny's
part before collaborating with him again. I would wonder where
the contrition is that you wanted to see or that you needed to
see and that I would wonder basically
um why when you said doxing was like that bad before we're like
basically saying okay well he can't really prove this and he
has maliciously lied about a bunch of people to try to harm them
um that now we're like well we don't really need to interrogate
the the reasoning for why he's doxing and calling for the death
of people. Um, so yeah. So hold on. Uh, if I if I'm trying to
summarize, it's like, am I either a hypocrite or a liar for saying
doxing is one of the worst things you can do? Not hypocrite.
Change your mind. I I don't need a hypocrite.
Uh, okay. Well, hold on. There was the doxing and then what was
the second one? Uh, saying, "I hope somebody these people." Um,
what? Death threats. Yeah. Then he Well, I guess you call him
death threats. I try to be more specific because if I ever get
like one iota off, he'll try to use that as like a meme lying
about him or something. So, yeah, sure. Um, so, uh, I I'm going
to go I'm going to go back in history to the best of my knowledge.
Okay. Um, so do I do I think was brought up in the in the context
of like, uh, etiquette and what was going on at the time was,
and I I might still feel this way. We'll kind of interrogate
this in a second, like I'm I'm thinking out loud basically. So,
the reason why I said doxing is one of the worst things you can
do as a creator is because I do think it's one of the worst things
that you can do. Like, barring like murder and right. And the
reason why I think I articulated in that conversation yesterday
is because we're all creators. We're all trying to make money.
We're all trying to gain an influence and and an audience. And
so, when you dock someone, effectively what you're saying is,
I don't give a if people are coming after you in a schizophrenic
way in order to try to hurt you. I don't care if people harass
you. And I don't care if um I'm trying to think of what else,
but that's like the main thing, right? Like you're trying to
put somebody in fear for their safety because you think they're
such a piece of And so normally that's outside of the rules of
engagement of the online discourse. Specifically, what was going
on at the time, even if it's not relevant, was I was contacted
by several people uh in reference to Kevin Cassley. I don't know
if you remember him, but Kevin Cassley had allegedly doxed a
few people and people were saying like, "Stay away." And I I
kind of had agreed at the time because I was like, "Yeah, that's
pretty up." Okay. Um I still think it's pretty up and and I I
guess that the question or not the question, but the statement
is right now I have, you know, Stephen saying, "Yeah, I don't
care if I dox Jtock Queen, Kelly Gene, and some other people."
And then when I ask him about it, he's basically saying that
you guys are already doing the same to him. And you're you're
saying that's just not true. Yeah, it's just not true. He is
totally making that up. It is fabricated whole cloth. Um, and
because it's fabricated whole cloth based on, and if I'm hearing
you correct, you're also saying that you deny that there's like
a I don't know, a cross-pollination between the drama community,
I guess, that like Queen and yourself have cultivated
in a way that I would be responsible for that calls for my doxing.
Um, obviously there could be people who look at Kiwi farms, but
like I can't possibly be held responsible for that. If I can
be held responsible for that, Destiny absolutely is a fair target
for all of these things. I think even you based on your hanging
around with Destiny, being in my Discord, being in Destiny's
Discord, it would all apply to you, too. Like, basically, this
is a this is a free it's it's all it's all it's a fire sale.
Everybody Everybody can be doxed and and uh apparently, which
is pretty insane. It's not a world I want to live in, but yeah.
Um I'm trying to think of how I feel about that. And and so the
the reason why I'm taking a second to kind of think about it
and feel about it is because on one hand I I I do believe you
in the sense that you're not doing anything particularly egregious
compared to the rest of the space and therefore it's kind of
crazy to presume that like you should suffer any like additional
you know additional harm compared to what you normally do. Um,
as far as I can see, like 90% of your activities are, you know,
effectively I I hate to use this term perhaps incorrectly, uh,
but basically like a logging like you basically just you just
document um, Steven's bad behavior and then hope that he crashes
out so it gives you more content. So before I before I guess
like Kelly Jean started talking about his girlfriend or something
in my Discord, I had mostly moved on. And I would say about 80%
of my time was on different stuff like non-destiny related. And
then since then, Jesus, since then, I've basically just had like
a whole bunch of like it's basically been him talking about it
or other people talking about it and like talking about this
general thing and he's just kept escalating, right? So it has
gone back more to Destiny, but that's just based on his actions.
Like if I if literally if he was if he had moved on, like I wouldn't
be covering his stuff. I would rather cover other things, right?
But unfortunately for me, it's just like this is good money.
This is what people pay me for. So, in your opinion, just out
of curiosity, what like re-triggered him? It was probably Kelly
talking about his girlfriend, wasn't wasn't just out of just
out of curiosity, wasn't that like a month ago as well? Yeah,
it was somewhere around this time. Maybe it was a couple weeks
ago. I'm not totally sure, but like I had I had largely like
I wasn't covering it very much. I I'd like moved on until he
started like literally targeting my Discord and saying that like
this was a place where revenge forms was getting posted or docs
were getting posted, which are both just totally made up like
whole cloth. Yeah. So, so, so let me tell you my aversion to
being like Destiny is a
monoomaniacal deviant
doxer murderer who's I don't need the hyperbole added, right?
I just like I think you could just say like he's doxing people
and trying to get them with like or like I calling for their
death with no evidence for the reasons that he's doing it. But
here's I I don't I don't really want to agree to that because
the the thing about it is like calling for their death. Do do
we take like uh for for instance like when
uh Xanderhal was losing his and he was like I want to I want
to Keles what's her address? I wouldn't even shoot her. I would
beat her with a gun. Are we taking that like we're not taking
that one seriously? Right. Did Xanderhal go to multiple YouTube
streams after that and justify those statements and say that
they were actually good and he was right in doing it? No, I don't
I don't think he necessarily formally apologized either, but
yeah. So, like I'm totally fine with people like crashing out,
but the repeated justifications are the concern. Continuing it
afterwards. So, in your in your opinion, um has he continued
this like recently or afterwards or was it just in the wake of
Sorry. Sorry. I'm saying he's justifying the death threats and
the doxing. He justified it to you. He justified it like on to
his stream like the day before. Right. So he's not saying, "Oh,
no. I just kind of got heated for a second." He's saying, "No,
no, no. Like I the these people like dox me."
Right. Right. And there's no proof of the reason. I'm not saying
it's accur his argument. I'm not saying it's accurate. I think
I need time to think about it. Um he's saying that like this
is reciprocal because you and Quean are doing the same thing
effectively.
Yes. Yeah. So, so I I think I think before like making a decision
on whether or not uh you know whose team or anybody's team really
um that I'm on uh I I I think I would need to like know the whether
or not any of that was true. I I think just factually I think
most of the people that have been doxed around Destiny got doxed
before the stuff was ever leaked. Like before like January 20th
or whatever when the studios came out, right? like the the doxing
stuff didn't happen in response to my coverage. Um that the one
thing he talked about was somebody on Kiwi Farms threatened Tom
Foolery, but it's like I don't know how I could be held responsible
for Tom Foolery getting threatened. I wouldn't want anything
bad to happen to Tom. I wouldn't want his docs posted. I wouldn't
want anything like that. Yeah, I'm being told that the Xander
thing was bringing this up more because it's funny, but like
wasn't there wasn't there like an entire like arc where you effectively
were called like to like a pest or a harasser just to get him
to crash out?
Uh yeah, but I literally said that I don't think he's actually
done anything. Like I literally said to him in the first conversation
I ever had with him and then gave him logs of me saying like
I don't actually think this, but then he started out about it
for some reason. Uh you know what, man? Like I I hate to be so
unsatisfying. Um but but I I I think I I would either need to
actually like try to evaluate the validity of Destiny's claims
in order to see whether or not like you're you're saying that
he's just like bald-faced lying about this. Um, or see if there
was like some kind of evidence of like some some people in like
Queenman's server or your server who are all playing footsy who
actually are actively trying to
uh, you know, Doc's girlfriend and Doc's family and this that
the other like like or if it's legitimately like you said, it's
all related to the Muslim [__] and it's all related
to the conservative [__] You have nothing to do with
it. Like I think all like some of it blends at the edges. I'm
not sure when certain people were doxed or something, but it's
like uh that behavior started way before I ever started covering.
Like he had this issue where people were around him were getting
doxed way before he actually talks about it in the thing with
you and he talks about Zoe and Jacob. They were doxed for being
around him when I was still like friendly with him when he was
still coming on my stream. This was all something that happened
based on his prior behavior that he is now loading on to me for
I don't know what reason. Well, correct me if I'm wrong. Uh,
wasn't that narrative and bear in mind I did not know about the
Zoey situation at all. Wasn't the narrative around that effectively
that like there was a bunch of people in Queenman and or your
chats who were harassing them for being associated with Steven
after it was already revealed that he was a bad guy, quote unquote.
And then uh basically they became like I don't know like you
know
minor celebrated figures within the discords once they said like
oh yeah Steven's like an evil guy and he can eat a piece of and
we hope he dies. Oh that they what happened. So what he's referring
to okay what he's again I also need like names but there's one
specific situation he's referring to where the person who docks
them they're like yeah we don't care about that guy. And that
guy was like oh yeah I don't care about them anymore. you're
a piece of but like it it yeah they I think they said like we're
good with him or something only now like the person that docked
them and the people that were getting docked. I think it was
basically like oh uh I like what happened was Zoe came back to
the Discord. He also made this up entirely. Uh he he's also maliciously
lied about like um Zoe being the person who like tried to coach
Cherry into making her tweet or something. Like he also just
totally made that up whole cloth. But uh Zoe came back to the
Discord because Zoe asked when Destiny was sending like videos
videos to her. She said, "Hey, uh, I only want these if the other
person consents." And then he sent them. And then she found out
that they didn't consent. Right? That's broadly what happened.
And she was like, "Oh, this guy's a total piece of and he made
me party." Wait, is that is that is that her narrative? Or have
people seen like DMs where she's like, "I only want these if
the other people consent." Wait, people have seen DMs of this?
Yes, I could pull the DMs out for you. They've seen DMs of her
saying, "I only want these other people consent." Yep. And what
what date what date was this? When when was this? This would
have been uh probably like uh December 2023 to February 2024,
maybe going back a little earlier in 2023. Okay, then I'm going
to I'm going to macro macro zoom out. Can you can you give me
a little bit of latitude real quick? And I'm I'm just going to
explain it from my perspective. Sure. Um yeah, again, I just
want to You want to keep going into the drama stuff? We can.
I don't care. I I just It's fine with me. It's just that um I
just want to say that a lot of times you guys like he'll say
there's a bunch of people who do this. This stuff all happens
here and all I ever want is connect that to me. Connect that
to Queen. Explain why you're doxing these people. Why wouldn't
you just go and try to like dox I don't know the the other people.
Why are you doxing? Why are you doxing calling for my death?
And realistically he he always does this. This is one other thing
I wanted to add. He always does this really stupid thing where
he's like oh just cuz they're smaller I'm not allowed to talk
about. It's like, no, literally analyze any one of my VODs, Destiny,
on your stream and point out where I'm lying. Like, I'm totally
fine with that. I have no issue with him actually attacking any
of the ideas I've said, any of the things I've said. I don't
have a problem with him attacking them. But, but like that's
not what he does, right? He doesn't attack them at all. He doesn't
actually engage with anything I'm saying. He just goes and like
doxes and calls for my death. Very odd. Very odd for a community
that apparently is all about talking things out. Yeah. So, so
this might go a little bit too wide. And if you need to reel
me back in, you know, feel feel free to. But I just I just feel
like kind of articulating my perspective is so so Stephen has
presided over Twitch and YouTube politics for probably what is
2025 right now. I don't know like eight or nine years, right?
Like I think I think he made his political switch in 2016 and
that's when the debate scene was big. I I came in the debate
scene in like 19. You know, it kind of died out in 22 23 and
then, you know, we've all been kind of living in the in the corpse
of Twitch and YouTube politics for, you know, 2 years now. And
I think that in 2020 through 2023, it was actually incredibly
like socially and financially lucrative to not just be Destiny's
orbiter, but also to be Dylan Burns orbiter, Prime Kai's Orbiter,
Vos's orbiter, right? there was like this really vibrant debate
space. And so I have nostalgia about that time period and I have
nostalgia about Destiny. I have some nostalgia about Vosch, believe
it or not. And I'm still very friendly with Dylan and I'm still
very friendly with Prime. Um, but the truth is the scene is kind
of like dead, right? And so there's not much of a clout boost
to be gained by like sweeping for Destiny and his misdeeds.
Um, okay. But there but there is maybe like a utility because
Twitch and YouTube politics does have a few hundred thousand
young, you know, dispossessed, angry, politically motivated people.
There is a utility to trying to get those people to either do
something with their lives or volunteer or whatever. And so the
utility for me is not in like, you know, I I need Destiny's like
quote unquote like money or clout. The utility for me is whether
or not we try to get a few hundred of these tens of thousands
of souls to actually go do some real. And it seems like Stephen
is the only person who's done that so far. And so, uh, you know,
let's use the midterms as an example. Okay. Um, coming up in
the midterms, there's going to be Hassan. We could we could cut
to the end of this. I like I I don't need to hear I we've all
heard this exact explanation. Just breaks down to the Jimmy Savile.
Yeah. If he saves two kids, he could rap one, right? like you're
just going to do the util thing. We could we can go there. Like
we could skip to the end of it, right? I get that like you think
it's important that you get people engaged and I get that you
don't have a replacement for Destiny, but it's like I'm I'm sitting
here and it's like a whole bunch of people told me like morally
they're against doxing. Morally they're against like viol like
encouraging violence online. I think Erdite talked about how
she wanted to politically split from Destiny over some of the
rhetoric he was he was doing, right? I just I wonder why like
essentially nobody called this guy out when he just called for
the death of like multiple creators and then justified calling
for the death of those creators repeatedly on his YouTube channel.
You know why? How does that not
I hold I'll tell you something. Uh because it to me it was funny
when it happened with BLM with the Kyle Writtenhouse thing. I
was like based it was kind of funny with the MAGA thing where
I was like yeah if you actually believe that Trump is a fascist
piece of [__] who's about to destroy this country
then you shouldn't give a whether or not one of his supporters
gets shot in the [__] face and I thought that was
funny too just being real. Um okay whether or not like Steven
legitimately wants a schizophrenic to murder you guys I have
no idea if that's his true intent. Um, and he's also using like
almost like a self-defense reasoning that I don't know whether
or not is actually true. Uh, I and by the way, this isn't like,
oh, we we need him. Like, like, no, I'm not saying that. We don't
need him. We don't need him for the midterms. That's not my point
at all. Um, the the point is like I don't know how much I give
a about his or the Discord. Like, so in order to verify everything
that you need to say or you just said, I would need to like go
into Discord and then start trolling through like pages of DMs
of people who have no Can I Can I ask you just really quickly?
Why did you accept whole cloth that narrative from Destiny without
any investigation? Why did you ask for him to accept the narrative?
And I I don't think I have accepted the narrative and I don't
know if I care to investigate it. Okay? Because like my my work
isn't reliant on Destiny. what I'm going to do over the next
year isn't relying on Destiny. Okay. All right. Uh, sure. That's
fine. No, but but but like but so so let me ask let me ask you
a question. Are you on on some level this is content, right?
You're you're going to clip it, post it. Conor's a hypocrite.
He's a piece of whatever. But well, I mean, I'm trying to keep
the actual tone of the conversation away from that, right? But
but are you I'm asking you because I'm trying to ask you on a
human level. Are you emotionally bothered that there are creators
like like Destiny? I I I think you used to be a fan, right? Are
you emotionally bothered by the fact that this person who got
a lot of charity from the Twitch and YouTube politics space and
who you used to be a fan of is coming after you and nobody seems
to give a like does that bug you emotionally or is it just like
oh yeah everybody's a hypocrite and a piece of like what what
what's I would say the the bother um emotionally maybe is that
like nobody actually had principles on any of these things when
everybody soyed out about Shauna Black and Mike from PA and Gremlow
calling for violence against Destiny when everybody retweeted
my tweets saying, "Hey, it's really for you to do this. This
is insane, actually." Right. I was the only person who believed
that. So, I spread that message that that was bad. But actually,
I'm ash because nobody else gave a Did you retweet those? Uh
I I don't I don't know if I retweeted those, but no, but they
like not liking general harassment and violence doesn't mean
that uh in certain situations if you think that people deserve
it that that makes you hypocritical. I don't think that's true.
Um sure, but then you're you're loading this all into the conditional
and saying that you don't want to investigate the conditional.
you've actually like moved the entire you've moved you've gotten
rid of the only question that exists is whether or not like and
I I would just wonder why there's nobody who's like uh kind of
like close to not even close to Destiny why there's aren't a
lot of people who like to investigate and figure this out right
well yeah yeah so no that that's actually again I would just
that's the practical thing so so the practical thing is there
there there's three people involved right now so let let's say
that I want to investigate this I want to get to the bottom of
this okay there there's three people involved who would actually
have access to the information. One of them would be Queman.
Uh no offense to Queman, but he's kind of like a and I literally
think that he lives to piss off people so much that they wish
death on him. Like I think that's actually the way that he operates.
And so I think that if I asked him, he would probably be honest,
but he also I don't think he's going to like troll through his
own Discord in order to find me logs of every schizophrenic that
he's ever had in the Discord to see whether or not one of them
went after Destiny or talked about going after Destiny. I don't
think that he cares that much. Would that justify this if there
was a skits in there who's like attached to human arms? Would
that like justify it? Let's say yeah, if there was somebody in
the chat that was like, "Hey, yeah, lol. I just got Destiny's
girlfriend's docs blah blah blah blah blah blah just
posted." And then Queen was like, "Hey, bro. We don't post about
that [__] here. Uh, you know, otherwise awesome."
You know, like like, yeah, then I I would see that. I think that
potentially justified in believing that they were playing footsie
in the back end, they just didn't do it on Discord, right? Oh,
so even if Quimman had a policy that like I'm going to delete
that and I'm going to get that person out of my Discord or something,
it wouldn't matter. You would just believe that that was happening
behind the scenes then? Um, uh, I think the kicked out of the
Discord would be the thing that I would look to to see whether
or not Queen legitimately didn't believe in that behavior. Like
if if he banned him, then I would be like, "Okay, he's probably
not playing footsie."
Um if he didn't ban him then I'd be like maybe he's playing footsie,
right? Doesn't that make sense to some degree? Sure. Sure. Um
yeah, I would just say broadly using like the justifications
you've used that like people could under your framework you've
presented here call for violence against you based on essentially
anything, right? Like you've and like you would have any moral
condemnation because you don't have a moral position on this
at all, right? If if they thought it was justified, right? Yeah.
Like it's it's literally the Trump um Trump thought he won the
election. Trump thought he won the election. So he was totally
justified in trying to take it back because that's what he thought.
He had a truly held belief that he won the election. So that
was actually he's not morally culpable for that decision to try
to take the election back, right? No, I don't I don't think we're
I don't think we're saying the same thing. He thought he was
justif. So, if I don't believes I don't know if Steven earnestly
believes that he's in a self-defense situation and he's acting
out of like uh reciprocal violence. I I don't I don't know if
he truly believes that or if there's just people who are critical
of him and he's like, "Yeah, these people lol ruin their lives.
Who gives a I'm assuming that you're saying it's the latter,
right?" Yeah. And so so my kind of my kind of question is um
if he if he were in a like a self-defense style situation so
to speak then he could be potentially justified because if I
if we did find DMs of people at from KF you know playing footsie
in your chat and Queman's chat then it would be reciprocal. Now
the easiest way to resolve that I think is to ask Stephen. Um,
but I but I almost guarantee you that he's in such a sensitive
spot that if I'm asking for that, then he's just gonna be like,
"Oh, okay. Well, you're a part of them, so you too." So, yeah.
So, so then that you're basically in the same position as all
the victims who are like, "Yeah, I'd speak up, but uh actually
might just put me on a target list." I mean, I don't care if
I'm on a target list. Um, okay. As a matter of fact, it why not?
Why not? I'll literally just DM them. And again, I just want
to I need proof that I was like somehow aware of this, right?
Like I don't spend very much time on my Discord. I would have
to be aware of this. Okay. Yeah. Give me Let me think about how
I want to phrase this real quick. I'll try not to leave too much
there. You could you could just send it after if you want. Like
I I'll believe you after now just because I don't want to um
you know whatever consistency we can glean from the conversation.
I kind want to do it now. Um Jay Stock and I are on a call in
order for it to be justifi or for your docs for death to be justified
the um what is it the plain footsie with KF docpin would need
like I've literally I don't think I've ever been on docin before
so sure we need to be I'm totally unaware of that site there
But do you have any hard evidence of
playing with those psychos?
Like the closest thing I could think is basically the guy Oh,
hold on. I'm just going to tell you the closest thing I could
think of is maybe he could say that the solo guy originally shopped
like the the original Lauren leaks in Queens Discord, but like
I told Destiny about that. Like I gave him a heads up on that.
So I don't even know. Like I gave him a heads up before Sunday
went live. And and maybe that'll be it. Maybe he'll just say,
"Oh yeah, you know, this this solo leaked it in their chat and
that'll be all of it." Which would declined to cover it. Yeah.
Like Queen declined to cover it. Um the guy happened to find
someday, but like I don't even know. Yeah, Queen deleted all
of them. He declined to cover it. I don't know what more was
expected there, but yeah. Anyway, yeah, indulge me another rant.
Okay, so macroing this out. Uh we there was and is a late 30-year-old
man who is a gooner who had sex with a bunch of women. The was
consensual. The video recording was consensual, but then he took
those video recordings and he said it without their consent to
a bunch of people. Right? Then allegedly he audio recorded consensual
counter encounters without those people's consent and then he
sent that around. Right? that that's what happened as far as
I understand right now. What's going on is in the wake of those
revelations of him engaging in reckless sec uh behavior that
damaged the public reputation of a bunch of people. Uh habitual
consent violations. The most accurate way I've heard of saying
it, habitual consent violations, I would say, but they weren't
all. So, okay. Um, yeah, he's basically saying that he doesn't
have the time or energy or interest in order to substantiate.
And he basically says that if I go into your stuff and then I
just search for his name and his girlfriend's name, then I'm
just going to find dozens upon dozens of people effectively just
pouring over every detail of their lives. You might find people
going over like some details of their lives. I think people Kelly
was like mad at his girlfriend, right? after he had made up a
bunch of malicious lies about Kelly. I think Kelly started attacking
his girlfriend, but is that a reason again? Would that be would
that be reason to dox me and then my death? Uh, and pro probably
not the the thing. So, here's my thing though. So, so I think
I did I accurately summarize the drama relatively speaking. Uh,
I mean I Yeah, I'd have like some superficial disagreements,
right? But it's fine as a fine summary. So, so in the wake of
that scenario, we have because correct me if I'm wrong, you what?
You get like what highund so like 700s 800 live viewers somewhere
in there depending on I no I haven't gotten 800 in a while like
um I yeah I I'm at 550 right now. Okay. Which I guess is not
that bad considering there's a bunch of other people live but
go ahead. Sure sure. So So you're between 500 and a thousand
live view live streamer. Queman is also between 500 and a,000
uh live viewers. God bless his soul. Good for him. Grinding.
Uh the So there's two communities that Stephen is alleging in
the wake of this drama have made it their effectively their life's
mission in order to endlessly talk about him and pray on his
d downfall, hope he goes to jail, hope he gets all his money
taken away from him, hope he gets his uh his platform taken away
from him, etc., etc. And so you're saying that we but these communities
as far as you understand are playing within the rules of the
internet as you understand them whereas Stephen is violating
them in order to come after you and Queen. So now we have a late
40-year-old man who has indiscretions and we have two communities
of several hundred people who are going after him and he's going
allegedly harder than they are. At what point that this this
is going to be a little, you know, dismissive. At what point
do I, as an almost 40-year-old man with two children and bills
to pay and a different job that focuses on different [__]
at what point do I just say, "You're all repulsive." And I just
walk away. Um, I mean, you could have done that at any point.
I just thought you like literally do streaming. You've had these
moral conversations. You've taken moral positions, right? So,
it's basically me asking you what's changed in your moral positions.
And I don't feel like you've actually given me satisfactory answers
on any of that. Right. Sure. Um, you could you could just opt
for that, but if if that was the decision you're going to make,
I feel like you wouldn't keep entertaining these conversations.
No, I I believe it or not, I I entertain these conversations
because a lot of people when I entered Twitch and YouTube politics,
whenever I asked for a conversation, they just said yes. And
so I try to have a pretty open door policy when it comes to conversations
because oftentimes like if you if you're not willing to have
the conversation it just looks like you're right. Um and then
it anyways it h rising tides help raise all boats right so if
a lot of people said yes to me they helped me with my YouTube
career they helped me with my stream if somebody asked me for
a conversation I want to say yes. So, uh, the this question or
let me answer your first question and then maybe we can move
to the the second question if there is a second question. Um,
I think I took a note on it earlier. You asked me what's the
difference between doxing is one of the worst things you can
do. I still think doxing is one of the worst things you can do.
Uh, one of the parties is claiming self-defense and I'm not sure
if I believe them and I think I need to think about it then.
I I think the second thing is the death threats. I do think it
actually is supered up for him to be like I would kill them.
I would I would choke them out if I could. It is kind of like
a Xanderhal moment. That's like embarrassing. Sorry. That's embarrassing.
I would say the combination of them and not saying well he said
both I choke them out if I could and I really want somebody to
go kill these people, right? I really want someone to kill these
guys. So I'd say the combination of trying to like doing his
best to post identities and calling for the death. I think that
combination is from the same person through his own accounts
is pretty insane and like an escalation that's not really a similar
escalation. I don't even think he did that to like Keles or something.
Ke's got his tush taken away. So the Yeah. So the in in reference
to that if I was the person that was on the receiving end of
that I would assume that we talked about like stochcastic verbiage
for a really long time uh in Twitch and YouTube politics. If
somebody did that to me, I would assume effectively assume that
they were trying to like stochastically
inspire one of their schizophrenic community members to either
harass me.
Yeah. Either harass me, do death threats, or even show up to
my place and either try to scare me or actually injure me. Sure.
Yeah. Do you um just out of curiosity, do you have any of the
recent stream clips from him justifying it after the fact? Uh
there's his justification with you and then there was one where
he's playing Factorio the other day that I don't have off the
top of my head. Hold on. Okay. Is it is it in a is it in a similar
I do have it off the top of my head. Boom.
Should I click watch stream? Yeah, click watch stream or let
me uh I just need to fix up OBS real quick. I won't have it off
of him.
Just saw a video where everyone losing their mind that just threatened
to kill just somebody cuz the I have like three communities on
ALS that are obsessively upote down voting all my [__]
Um, people are I think I don't even remember this. Oh, can you
rewind? Thank you for the five seconds. Can you rewind five seconds?
I'll restart it. I'll restart
Decades. Real quick though, I'm just going to do a show real
quick since I've got most of my audience here. Uh, guys, if you
like the content, go ahead and throw me a couple subs. Throw
me a couple bucks. Exclamation boy. Donate in the chat. We'll
give you the donation links. Okay, you can go join the Patreon
as well. patreon.com/jslk. Any support you give is appreciated
and adds time to the stream. Thank you very much. Okay, let's
go. It's not just saw a video where everyone losing their mind
that Destiny threatened to kill just somebody because I have
like three communities on LSF that are obsessively upote down
voting. Oh my [__] People are say up vote down vote
up vote down voting. He's saying that like uh he's getting astroturf
down votes on LSF.
Stalin a slot. Thank you for the 5k. This was like months ago.
But somebody basically asked me I think Willy Mack asked me something
like oh like how do you feel about Oh you messaged him while
he was live on anything else. Apparently brought it up there
too. uh these people whatever and I was like if you're somebody
that is actively engaged in a community that is like spam linking
revenge of me revenge uh docs of me docs of so revenge of me
docs of me neither of those things have ever been done hold on
so revenge of me and and sorry I'm I'm writing these down
revenge of me docs of me cyber drifter thank you for the 10 gifted
let's go a community there's like spam linking revenge of me
revenge uh docs of me docs of my girlfriend revenge for my like
if you're doing all so docs of me revenge of me docs of my girlfriend
revenge one of my girlfriend um none of those things I I believe
have ever been linked to my discord I think um I don't recall
it happening and people have said it didn't happen but like it
wouldn't shock me if somebody got really overzealous and posted
like some clip from her uh my free cams or something um I don't
think that would be revenge like you're selling on the internet
necessarily. Um, and Destiny did the same thing to Kelly Gene,
posting her Only Fans content in his DG chat. So, I'm not sure.
Wait, sorry, say that very last sentence again. Uh, Destiny also
posted only fans content from Kelly Jean in his DG chat. And
that was before she allegedly posted pictures of heroid butthole.
I don't I don't know if it was before after. And I don't know
if she posted that. I don't think she posted that, but she says
she didn't. I have no idea. I have not investigated to know for
sure. Okay. So where? Let let me ask let me ask you the So I
I believe her when she says she did. Okay. So let me let me ask
you this question. So we got uh allegedly. Okay. Allegedly. We
got Lav uh posting pictures of Destiny as a Discord username
on a Discord with like a few dozen or a few hundred people, right?
I think we got Kelly Jean as a part of that Discord. Even if
she doesn't do that. Nope. Kelly Jean was not a part of that
Discord. That's made up as far as I know. Okay. Then we have
Kelly Jean at least making fun of his girlfriend's butthole.
Yep. Uh then we have Quean and yourself. None of the love content
conduct happened on my Discord, by the way. Sure. It it was just
Lav I I I think he's saying that uh you platformed and by the
way I don't give a [__] I'm saying what he said.
Platformed uh Mr. Girl and Lav. Did you platform Mr. Girl? Um
after all this bro What did Mr. girl. Wait, why why would I be
able to get doxed for Mr. Girl being platformed? Uh, just because
this is like the the cabal of people who are praying on Destiny's
downfall. Okay, I platform Mr. Girl with other people with Dan
and Allrele relevant in the call pushing back against what he
was saying, by the way. No, no, I'm not adding this up to a case
where I think it's appropriate. Um, I'm trying to I'm trying
to follow the logic chain, so to speak. I'm just pointing out
how the logic chain is. Sure. as and then and then effectively
I guess the insinuation is that queen in your communities communities
have to be partially made up of people who love perusing and
posting to Kiwi Farms. But I also think that that's like that's
kind of an unfair charge, right? Cuz if you're a bigger streamer
entirely have schizophrenics in your chat? Yeah. Well, and my
community is built entirely from his community. And my community
has like the same like most active chatters that it's had since
I've basically first started streaming. Yeah. So, so the question
is, have you done anything sufficiently to the point besides
being the people who are praying on Steven's downfall, have you
done anything sufficiently to the point that warrants doxing
or threats of violence? And I will say when Kelly posted that
stuff in the Discord, um Lena, Destiny's girlfriend, reached
out to me and based on the stream conversation we had said, "Thank
you for defending me and saying like, "You don't appreciate that.
You don't want that around." right and basically pushing back
on anything Kelly was saying and saying it was like crazy. Um,
people in the Discord broadly push back against Kelly like attacking
his girlfriend as well. The overall tenor of the Discord is no,
we don't do that here. Um, and Destiny knows that for a fact,
but he will lie about it. Yeah, then I mean Yeah, then I I think
I think I can I can land on I can understand emotionally how
Steven would land on a point where he's like, "Yeah, it all these
people." But I also think that he's just incorrect. Um, I I I
think Yeah. Yeah, I'll just I'll just say that I I think that
he's incorrect to be doxing obviously for all the reasons that
I listed of why we have the rules that we have unwritten, but
the rules that we have as creators. And then I think he's also
wrong to stochcastically call for your potential death or Queenman's
potential death because I don't think in so far as the behaviors
that I've observed and know of um all of this feels like part
of the game. Well, I mean it's so it's maybe it's part of the
game. Um you guys went over the Anna stuff as well. I'd love
to go over that with you before we uh wrap this up, but it's
it's broadly just his pattern. He's going to try to like terrorize
the people who have criticisms for him. It's just broadly the
pattern that exists, right? It's what he did to Anavar. Um you
It's weird cuz you did the whole Mr. Girl report review. I think
you went through theore section and then when Destiny said I
didn't do anything like manipulative um it literally says that
they were 2 days before he posted her Kiwi Farms thing and then
he goes well I didn't do that to like with her I did that to
like get it out of my community and then when we go to the DMs
like if you want to stay in this uh
um when we go to the DMs like I'll read you the DMs it's it's
quite literally like hey if you if you stop uh this yourself
yeah up here. Okay, so the the DMs Anna says, "What the is wrong
with you, dude? You just outed that Kiwi Farm about me, dude.
You are horrible." He says, "I have a media blackout related
to your stuff, and I wanted to get everyone Oh, I'm covering
this up for stream." Well, you guys aren't going to see it. You'll
see Conor's face. I have a media blackout related to your stuff
and I wanted to everyone to get it out before uh people were
talking about it incessantly over the next two weeks as more
and more people discovered it which is like okay you are constantly
the second paragraph is where um when he says oh I didn't do
it to like make her stop talking but I didn't do it to do you
are constantly talking about me on your stream so I think it's
fair for me to bring it up you went as far to say I I was abusive
to you the last time you mentioned me she says because you threatened
to leak my no news you sociopath you literally ruined my life
you just dox me on stream you you put me in danger. You're doing
it. He says, "You're doing it to yourself." You're going to keep
doing it to yourself. When you keep talking about me, even if
I say something like, "I'm going to leak your nudes if you talk
about me anymore." Uh, you're doing it to yourself, actually.
So, I would say this is very much, "Hey, you have to stop what
you're doing and I will dox you and terrorize you." And I'm justified
in doing that because you have talked about me. And uh, sorry,
what was the characterization? His characterization 2 days. Show
me anytime I'm trying to manipulate a narrative or manipulate
somebody into like silence. trying to get Anna to shut the up.
Um, okay. We can watch the here. We can watch the clip on it
if you like, but it's like name a time I've show evidence of
my manipulation. I would say this is very manipulative. Um, like
the oppressor oppressy dynamic that because a person might be
smaller than me or whatever, I'm not allowed to say anything
back. I reject that framework. And so, everybody thinks he's
allowed to say something back. He's allowed to look at their
statements and then respond to those statements, right? Reveal
information that responds to those statements. I would say responding
or I'm not oh it's they're a small creator so I'm not allowed
to do anything back does mean probably I mean doesn't really
matter the size of the creator probably your response to somebody
saying incorrect things about you shouldn't be to dox them or
post their docs and amplify their docs right okay entirely um
I would say from now on um and I've said this for a while although
my personal life isn't as much in the spotlight anymore if you
want to criticize me for being like manipulative or controlling
or some then you need to post examples of that it's not enough
to just say oh because Destiny He spoke about this on stream.
He's abusing his power. That's
um so I would say the example of him being abusive here is that
he was her two days before he posted he he said on stream, "Here's
her Kiwi Farms thread." Right. Right. Yeah. So, just uh just
giving you the read. I'm not saying that you don't have an accurate
read. I'm saying that u I want to I want to show you my thought
process. So the first paragraph, I have a media blackout related
to your stuff and I wanted everyone to get it out before people
were talking about it incessantly over the next two weeks as
more and more people discovered it. That uh could like hypothetic,
not hypothetically, uh theoretically could be the narrative of
I didn't want it on my subreddit. I didn't want it in my community,
so I wanted to burn it out in Kiwi Farms instead of having it
leak into my community. That that's however Sorry. Go ahead.
We We both know that's the most thing either of us has ever heard,
right? If I if I went and said, "Okay, why you think some new
Revenge of Destiny just leaked? I'm going to direct you guys
to it and I'm going to give you a link to it because I don't
want you talking about it in my community. I want you to go talk
about it on the subreddit or on the message board where it is,
right? That would be an insane thing to do." No. So that this
is where you you can call me I'm going to explain my logic. dramas
seem to come and go uh no matter how bad they are and the faster
they get consumed, the faster they get burnt out. So I can almost
see the logic of I want this to burn out and I want this to burn
out away from me. Like can I just point out as an example
um Hunter Avalone had one of the craziest dramas that's ever
happened ever. I have not heard that brought up in the last 12
months except for a retrospective by Chud. You know what I'm
saying? Like like even even the worst burns out. Okay, that was
all information that was like released. It was like embarrassing,
but it's not like personally uh endangering material, right?
Unless you're talking about him ending himself, but I would say
that broadly like that also propagated through normal channels,
right? I don't know. Like to me to me again the hypothetical
I'm giving you is I can't I can't burn out Destiny's new tape
leaks or revenge leaks by saying here that here's the link don't
talk about it anymore right that would be I I'm just going to
ask you to say that that's I want you to tell me that that's
insane please no that yeah that that's crazy pants cuz obviously
even if it even if it's majority in the opposite community it's
going to spread everywhere else. Uh yeah. No, I I get that. I
I get that. It's uh it's Can I ask you? Well, so so can you can
you bridge a gap for me? So if they're if they're two days before,
what happened in those 48 hours for this like about face? What
was it like an Anna stream where she's like I am guessing Anna
said something. I'm guessing Anna said something and then he
said if she's going to leak any of my details because I remember
this. I'm guessing is if he if she leaks any of my details, I
will
um I'll leak stuff about him, right? Or sorry, I'll leak stuff
about her nudes or some [__] Yeah, I remember people
defending that. I think this is before I got into the community,
so little sparse details there. Yeah. So, let me uh let's try
to macro it. Let's try to macro it a little bit. Can you hold
on to your thought? I don't know if I could hold on to mine.
What's that? Sorry. Can you can you hold on to your thought cuz
I don't know if I could hold on to mine. I just want to point
out, yeah, go ahead. Why would why would Destiny himself need
to burn out anything from Kiwi Farms unless he had Kiwi farmers
in his chat who would be following it and looking for the link
and posting the link and then which is the sin he's currently
accusing you of. Yeah. So, okay, I I'm tracking and I'm absorbing
and I'm uh I'm groing. Okay. I'm I'm processing information.
Let Let's uh let's kind of like resummarize just so I can ground
myself. Yeah. You want to go? I I had that conversation with
Stephen because obviously this drama happened. A lot of people
wanted me to take like a really harsh stance really early on.
I refused obviously and then things have kind of settled a little
bit, but they're still simmering in the background because we
have the pending lawsuit, etc. The reason why I wanted to have
that conversation is because I was genuinely curious what his
moral uh philosophy and system was like in 2022 versus what it
was like or what it is now. And while I feel like we discussed
the overall like I don't know hedenism, stoicism, the 11 arisatilian
virtues, how he perceives his moral obligations separate from
his pleasure seeeking, we really didn't get in my opinion a definitive
separation between his previous philosophy and his current philosophy.
And so that's scary. you know, a as a friendly associate of his.
Uh, I think that's obviously scary because then that means that
like despite all of the negative consequences that have occurred
as a result of what I would call pleasure- seeeking behavior,
that still means that it's quite possible that it could happen
again, right? Because he he would think that like, oh, I I have
my moral obligations and my pleasure seeeking perfectly attuned.
Therefore, uh, what I'm doing right now is perfectly fine. But
then he's just jumping on another rake that smashes him in the
face. Um, yeah. So, that's scary. I'll say that's scary as a
as a friendly associate of Stevens. But then but then I guess
like what what is your you've kind of rebutted his accusation.
What else uh should we be addressing? Uh, so I wanted to go through
the Anna thing and just point out that like clearly that's like
when you I felt like you would push back more there. And you
could say like your focus was just not on um basically what when
he was addressing individual pieces or something because you
wanted to have a broad philosophy talk. I just would have expected
when you went over the Mr. Girl report like a month before that
to kind of have this in your head and know that basically like
this is this is probably insane. And it is like it is a part
of a pattern of behavior. This pattern of behavior has repeated
itself for years right at this point and it's shown no real that
there's contrition or any real change needs to be made. Yeah.
And and I've given up on contrition by the way. Uh, the reason
why I've given up on contrition is because I've kind of come
to the whether regardless of whether or not I like him or regardless
of whether or not I work with him in the future, I don't know
if he's psychologically capable of contrition. Uh, the the way
that I think normal psychology works is you up, you realize you
up, you feel guilty, you feel a little bit of shame, you apologize,
you atone, you show that you're contrite, and then regardless
of whether or not that person forgives you, you move on. That's
like the normal cycle, right? But I think that with Stephen's
pleasure seeeking, I'm just gonna be very honest. I I think that
with his pleasure- seeeking behavior, uh he might be abusive,
but he also attracts uh either personalities that are attracted
to abuse or personalities that they themselves are abusive in
certain ways. And so as a result, he always has a justification
for why the opposite party is incorrect and wrong and deserving
of his wrath. And so he'll always have a narrative of how they
did him wrong and why they deserve the poor treatment that he's
meeting out to them. Indulge me just one more rant. Part of the
reason why I asked about the turn the other cheek Christian philosophy
and I also asked about do unto others as you would like to be
done unto you
versus do unto others as they do unto you. Uh is because I think
that Steven operates under the latter and if he wanted to end
the cycle of abuse he would go to the former. Sure. He doesn't
operate on the latter either though. He operates on like the
is it the untouchables? um send one of ours to the hospital,
we send one of yours to the morg. That's like the standard he
operates on, right? Like no matter what you do to me, the thing
he actually accused and projected onto Kelly Jean where he was
like, "Oh, you just escalate an insane amount." Uh he just escalates
an insane amount, right? Basically always like without any concern
for control or how it looks to anybody around him. And then he'll
try to justify it and because he's built up like a cult-like
audience. And just like you said, you actually described this
because there's actually a second sphere around Destiny that's
not just his audience, but it's like the uh enjoined like Twitch
politics sphere that's all used to the way he makes arguments.
Very very um they'll be listening with an open ear for the way
he makes arguments and they will basically agree with him when
he's saying insane things. I think that happened to you in this
conversation where like he's just like, "Yeah, um like I don't
want to get into it, but basically there's some people who are
like kind of attached to something that's kind of attached to
something that's kind of attached to Kiwi Farms." And so even
though Jay-Z might not be aware of any of it and even though
Queen might not be aware of any of it, um yeah, I I am going
to dox them and tell people to kill them. And it's like that's
that's an insane sequence of statements to make and then people
kind of just nod and go, "Oh, yeah, that makes sense." Well,
and the the claim the claim is uh do unto others as they are
doing to you, but that if you were going to follow that moral
system, then of course you would actually have to prove that
others are currently doing that to you. And then but but this
is where this is where it gets uh to my sympathy and my empathy,
right? The I sympathize and empathize with people who have been
like docs, harassed, whatever. You know, I've had a few ugly
messages. I've had a few people say some nasty things to me.
Uh but I I haven't had anybody show up to my house. I haven't
had anybody swap my house. I haven't had anybody uh threatened
death to my wife or kids. I used to as a law enforcement officer,
but I haven't had that as a streamer or a YouTuber.
And so I'm actually sympathetic to that part of it. And I also
understand that when you're under threat, pretty much everything
feels like a threat. And so I I don't know if he I don't want
to go so far as to say like he's
consciously appealing to my empathy and sympathy for the amount
of harassment he's endured over the past like year and a half.
Um, but I would say that like it makes a certain amount of emotional
sense. So even if you and Quean aren't part of the cabal that's
attacking him, you are, I don't know, attacking his public reputation
and praying on his downfall. And therefore, you're getting swept
into the many people who have been harassing him wrongly or rightly
over the past two years. Yeah. But then to me that's like uh
I would hope that the people he's close to andor that he like
um would somewhat care about the opinions of would basically
go that's insane because that opens all of us that that means
everything that's been done to him is also justified right now
that he's done this he is he has said that it is actually fine
his behavior has put everybody else around him at risk right
and like now based on his own justification not mine I I strictly
say over and over and over again I don't advocate for any collateral
damage damage. That's not my MO. I don't like that. If I have
a problem with somebody, I'll go after them. Right. But he is
now going for he's basically got people on Kiwi farms that he's
blaming me for their behavior, right? And now I'm collateral
damage. He's just he's just green lit everything on everybody
else and he has no moral leg to stand on. We probably agree on
that, right? That if anybody can be connected to him and his
system of abuse, he now Yeah. Unless he was somehow able to substantiate
that you were like knowingly playing footsie with the most nefarious
parts of Kiwi farms who were actively engaging in swatting and
doxing of him and his girlfriend. Unless that link was established,
then yeah, I I don't I under the moral philosophy of do unto
others as they are doing unto you, you're that that's not even
correct under that philosophy, which I think is not a great philosophy.
Sure. Yeah. So, no, I'm I'm with you. I'm with you. And uh what
what I would say is let's just uh macro it. Um from a a moral
evaluation standpoint, I think that if he's going to publicly
say that he is not only okay, he is encouraging you, Kelly Jean,
and Queen to be doxed and he thinks that you're playing cute
with uh nefarious communities. I think that he needs to establish
that link or else it's wrong. Like like totally wrong. flat wrong
and even then it's probably not a good thing. It's not it's not
morally it's not the best moral system. I would just say it has
to link to me and then like I can I could probably show you logs.
I'm I'm sure I could go find in my mod chat somewhere where we
like banned links to KF or any images from KF because it was
like oh people are starting to post. No, we don't want that.
We don't want that like association, right? So it's like yeah
and there has to be reasonability. You you can you can only reasonably
do so much, right? That I I think that and he's a creator. He
understands that he has schizophrenic parts of his audience.
He can't police every single bad thing that DGGers say. Uh so
if he understands that he cannot police all of the negative behavior
of DGG, then he needs to understand that you and Que can't police
all of the negative behavior of your respective communities.
Yeah. And I guess then his only leg to stand on them would probably
be me having Kelly Gene on stream while she was talking [__]
about his girlfriend. But again, she wasn't like doxing her or
calling for threats on her or anything like that. she was just
talking [__] and like and broadly the community as
a whole pushed back against her almost entirely, right? So it's
like the the thing he's talking about is the the core of the
community is like these Kiwi farmers or doxers, but basically
everybody was like, "Please don't do that." Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I I think I think I'm landing on solid ground psychologically,
even if it took me a while to get there. So, uh what I would
say, and by the way, if you want to give me something else mentally,
uh that's totally fine. But what I would say I would advocate
publicly is obviously Christian morality which is turn the other
cheek when you can and also do unto others as you want done unto
you. I think that Destiny's philosophy of eye for an eye and
tooth for a tooth and then some is obviously not working out
and I would say that it's hurting people and we've been dealing
with two or three years of the fallout of what he did in 2022.
And so I think it's time for the cycle of [__] to
stop. So he my recommendation to him would be to stop the [__]
And if you're going to be reciprocal, if you're going to advocate
for violence, if you're going to advocate for doxing, then you
need to actually establish the evidence that justifies you morally,
or else I think people should would have uh correct cause to
doubt. Yeah. And like realistically, I'm sure he's going to find
people who in my Discord have made like references to things
on Kiwi Farms, but it's like where's the what am I supposed to
do? Like I like you'd have to have Yeah. some reasonability there.
I I don't know. Like people might do memes. I we do the 17-year-old
meme, right? that how old was Rose? But like realistically, I
talked to Destiny. Solo talked to me as well. And I talked to
Destiny about Solo and Destiny was the one who said because I
I actually tried to protect Destiny. I I tried to call him. I
actually said, "Don't I'm not going to put this in text because
it's like concerning to me." I tried to call him and he's like,
"Oh, it's about the underage thing, right?" And I was like, "Yeah,
this solo guy who leaked your just told me that this girl's 17.
Was 17 when you first started getting news from her?" And he's
like, "Oh yeah, she he told me that, too." He's like, "Yeah,
I'm not not really sure about that. He thought she was 19." Just
to be clear, I'm not saying he thought she was 17. Um, but he
he expressed that like he did an ID check. He joked a lot about
her age, right? And he did an ID check, knew she lived with her
parents. There's like a lot of concerning things there. So, we
meme about that, but that's all from primary sources. That's
from like Destiny himself saying that he didn't know how old
she was. He didn't do an ID check. He didn't know much about
her. So, like I Right. And yeah, and and this is where I would
in a in a correlative way, I would say that uh if if we were
to take the most dry description of this behavior, I would say
that in 2022, Destiny's pleasure-seeking behavior was out like
like insane. And uh he he forsook his moral obligations to the
broader community. And then he's saying that he's recalibrated
that in the modern era. Uh but we need to see that evidenced
and I I don't think a good way to evidence that is by saying
anybody who criticizes my not even criticizes my previous behavior
but uh basically anybody who comes after me for my bad behavior
in the past uh you know if you associate with schizophrenics
then I'm going to unleash a schizophrenic mob upon you. I don't
I don't know if that's the best way to turn a new leaf. And I
think you'd have to agree that I would be totally justified in
trying to go to like YouTube, like trying to email people at
YouTube about this, him like justifying death threats against
me on his stream, right? I would be totally fine creating like
a packet of information for future political collaborations that
I could say, "Hey, just so you know, this is the guy you're engaging
with. These are the behaviors he undertakes." I think all of
that would be totally fair game, right? The the T So when it
comes to the the toos or whatever, you know, we're we're all
slaves to it, so I get it. Um, I get it. I didn't I didn't say
I was going to do those things. I am incredibly anti flagged.
Even when he tried to mass flag me for using an F-sler about
him on stream when I was describing how he had uh non-conensually
recorded a friend of mine when I when I did it one time and he
called for mass flagging my channel, I still said don't do anything
in return. It's whatever. We should leave it alone. But now it's
gotten to like an insane extent and I think I would be totally
justified. I haven't really thought about it that much, but ju
just out of curiosity, do you think if you emailed him he would
ever talk to you? Uh, probably. Probably. You think he would?
I think so. Have you considered that as a course of option or
course of action? No. Why not? I'm not talking about private.
Uh, I was talking about public, but either way, I Why not? I
don't know why I would want to. Why would you want to? What What
does he have left to threaten me with? How How can he like I
don't need to
He's already done everything. It's actually threats. Okay. It's
not about threats. The This is a weird perspective, but it's
true. oftentimes when I'm when I'm dealing with uh people who
are being terrible,
uh I'm probably thinking most about my time in law enforcement.
Um I I oftentimes tried to give them outs, right? I tried to,
you know, re, you know, reach out to them, you know, mentally,
emotionally, socially, whatever, and try to say like, "Hey, man,
like you're you're up in this way, that way, the other way. There's
another way that we could do this. Here's the other way that
we could do this. Let's talk about it." And sometimes there would
be people who would take an out and then as a result we would,
you know, avoid worse consequences and then sometimes there are
people who just absolutely insisted on doing things the hard
way and as a result we did things the hard way. And so that's
where for me if we're effectively summarizing the fact that Destiny
had horrible indiscretions and then there's a drama fallout between
his critics and himself and he's engaging in ways that you know
if you wanted to see him turn over a new leaf, he's not engaging
in those ways, saying that to his face could be the difference.
So it could be the difference between him turning a new leaf
and him not. Okay.
Um, I don't think I'm the person who could do that. Uh, not after
you said all the He would need to he would need to make amends,
right, in some way. No. Uh, yeah. Why wouldn't you be Why would
you be able to say, "Hey, these are all the ways that I think
you're up. These are all the ways that I think you're over me,
uh, me over and other people over. Um, here's everything that
you've morally justified, and here's all the things that I think
I would be morally justified in doing to you based off of your
current behavior. Do you want to talk about it?" Sure. He can't
escalate anymore on me. That doesn't matter. I'm not talking
about escalating. It does matter to me that he I'm almost talking
about deescalating. Oh, I know. But I'm saying that what what
reason do I have to deescalate right now because hopefully he
would be because because he's not he's barring new revelations.
He's not going anywhere. Like he will have a community. He will
have tens of thousands of live viewers. He will be a a portion
of Twitch and YouTube. Will that community ever not hate me?
It doesn't matter. Who cares? They hate me and I'm like the I
I I went in there with kids gloves and they still hate me. Who
cares? Um I am not really interested in with no Yeah. Like broadly
this guy is just acting like a deranged lunatic and endangering
all of his stuff. And realistically with the uh hurt he's caused
to a lot of people around me, I'm I'm like fine with that. Uh
if he if he's going to take shots at me and Queman and a couple
other people, um he's done it now. You can't really do anything
about it, right? He's done it now. I'm like, okay, I actually
feel like what's that? What about future people? I don't think
he'll ever stop. I don't think he'll ever stop until he's forced
to stop, until he sees consequences. And I don't think he's seen
major consequences yet. So, you you think he's irredeemably down
this path and there's no changing course? No. But I think he
is accepting he need he is like years of therapy away from meaningfully
changing as a person, right? Like he needs to he needs to maybe
not I don't know if stepping away is the right idea, but he needs
to basically like admit some wrongdoing um and make some like
do some acknowledgement that he's lived his life in like a totally
incorrect way and that things need to change. But there's been
nothing like that, right? You can say psychology would allow
him to do that. I don't think his psychology allow him to do
that. Then I think then I do think if his if you're just going
to say his psychology won't allow him to do that. If I take that
assertion which I don't believe but if I were to take that assertion
then he is actually irredeemable, right? He will keep doing this.
So yeah. So let me let me explain something at least as far as
I understand it. Okay. So when it come I I don't know if he's
like a a diagnosible sociopath or psychopath but often times
with sociopathic people psychopathic people they can still judge
like moral goods and bads
uh they but they often operate from a sense of self-interest
right okay and so when it comes to a sense of self-interest if
you're able to you know Stephen in my opinion is somebody who
values uh rhetoric logic all that kind of stuff he can be erratic
at times s. Um, but he does he does value that, right? And so
having someone one of his most ardent critics coming to him and
logically laying out all of the ways in which he's up and saying
like, "Hey man, like you're you're not only hurting everyone
else, you're hurting your yourself, which he should realize already,
but it just might be different having his one of his most ardent
critics laying out his sins before him." Um, I think that would
be an opportunity to say, "Oh, well, this isn't just hurting
everyone else. This is also hurting me." I don't have any belief
that any change of his with no like I don't I would never believe
that he's changing, right? Like, broadly, he has just been able
to get away with this and to like threaten other people into
stopping covering him, stopping talking about him, stop pursuing
whatever they're pursuing against him, right? It's just a consistent
pattern over time. I have no particular interest in changing
him. You can do it. Molina and Dan tried for years. Sure. Yeah.
I just like I like literally What? Have you watched Destiny's
content at any point where there isn't somebody in his life?
Molina, not so erodite. I'm sure I'm sure going back to like
Yellow Spoon Girl and some other people. People being like, "Hey,
you can't I brought it up in that conversation. I remember I
remember Molina saying that if you continue to engage with drama
content this way, then you're going to lose everyone that's close
to you." I remember that quote almost vividly. Okay. So, no,
no, I'm I'm with you. And and I actually uh this might be a little
personal, but I'll just say it anyways cuz the truth hurts, right?
Um when this drama unfolded
uh I was talking to my wife about it and I told her it's like
this would be the equivalent of losing I have a friend named
Tony. I love him like a brother and then I have my wife obviously.
So if I if I had done something and I had lost my wife and I
had lost Tony, they said you did something so up that we can't
be around you, then I wouldn't be looking for anyone to blame
but myself because they're such fundamentally good people that
I would know that I had [__] up. Right? So if you're
losing the people who are most important to you in your life,
then that's not an evaluation of all of their sins, that should
be an evaluation of your sins. Yeah, this is our relevant said
something like this um around the first day that Dan was like,
"Wait, um like don't you think as a friend you have like a responsibility
to stick by your guy?" And our relevant responded, "No, he had
a responsibility not to engage in these acts like he's the leader
of my political project. He's he's like one of my friends or
at least I think we're friends or whatever. Like we're friendly
and he had a responsibility to like at the people around him
to not act like this to not do these things and he failed like
it's not. So I'm agreeing with you by the way just in case that
wasn't obvious. No, that's fine. Yeah. Uh maybe uh maybe I'm
a glutton for punishment. Maybe I'm a massochist but uh I'm still
I'm still going to be praying, you know, pray actually like praying
for him and hoping that he comes around. So sucks. [__]
sucks. Yeah. Well, I think the bigger thing to me is that like
unfortunately you you could say all this and you're like, "Yeah,
I totally agree with you. He's actually reallyed up and he is
like really with you guys in a totally unfair way." And then
it's like, "But I am going to approach him about canvasing."
It's like it's like a million voter contacts or whatever it was.
I'm like 1.6 million voter contacts. It's like 1.6 million voter
contacts. Uh, how many voter contacts do you think the equivalent
is for people remembering Destiny calling for that for uh that
firefighter or laughing at that firefighter getting killed? Do
you think that counts as like negative,000?
50,000 50,000 votes per death threat. That's my ratio. Well,
I was I was saying more the Republican thing cuz for me it's
like it's not even remotely solved that Destiny is like a positive
for the Democrat party even with the the canvasing. Like that
is not something that people know at all based on how inflammatory
he is, how much of a piece of he is, right? How hatable he is
to everybody. Uh, everybody who's who doesn't hate the exact
he Oh, well, I I hope he I hope he's not, you know, it's we didn't
get 1.6 million votes, right? It's 1.6 million voter contacts.
But but let's just say I I hope that uh Steven isn't so politically
repulsive that he's, you know, he's he's a negative past 1.6
million vote contacts. That'd be quite a lot of damage. Uh I'm
not saying it's not possible. I'm just saying I I hope I hope
that's not the case. The uh Yeah. So, hold on. Let me let me
share something with you, though, just because I feel like you're
smart enough to appreciate it. So, the what's happening right
now is alter alternative media. Uh politicians are trying to
figure out how to maybe not control, but control alternative
media and turn it into a tool. that's what they're trying to
figure out. And so there's a lot of people who have already done
this
successfully. The problem is that they're some of the biggest
pieces of on the internet. And so the question is how do you
get people who I don't know actually care about things like actually
care about communities, actually care about the welfare of the
United States, actually care about, I don't know, principled
things. Um how how do you take the energy and passion that's
in alternative media and turn it into something real? And nobody's
figured it out yet. And so even if Stephen uh let's say he's
like a serial killer, right? I'm not saying he is. Let's say
he is. And in one year or two years,
uh we were, you know, the Democrats choose to canvas with him.
They use him. They get DG to do 1.6 million more voter turns
out turnouts. And then it's revealed that he's like a serial
killer, right? Yeah. Well, there's still technically you would
kind of know before, right? What's that? Because now you you
know already about the serial killer thing. It would be we're
we're raising this serial killer up because he's going to get
us votes. We're giving this guy power and a ton of a bigger audience,
huge way of victims, and then we're going to him because we'll
get votes. Well, for the for the sake of my hypothetical, I wouldn't
know that he was a serial killer until it was revealed, right?
Uh so so the point is that like we're still going to learn lessons
of taking an alternative media figure and then trying to translate
that into real world action even if that person is a bad person
or is later revealed to be a bad person. And so this is the frontier
and who figures it out first does matter. And right now uh some
of the worst people on the planet are dominating the sphere.
So I care about it. I'm going to work on it. Uh, I I I don't
know what that means for Stephen and I's future. I don't know
if we're friends. I don't know if we're collaborators. I don't
know what the we are, but that that's uh that's where I'm at.
I just feel like you admitted that this guy's like a fairly bad
person who hurts a lot of people and has shown no indication
that they'll stop hurting people. And then you followed that
up by saying, "But I do want to raise his profile. I do want
to make him as big as I possibly can because I think it's good
for votes. I will just be your pay." Yeah, I I care I care more
about votes than I care about homemade leaks, whatever the [__]
Yes. Will PV be contacting him? Okay. All right. Uh can I ask
you based on all of this, why would Destiny be a better choice
than Hassan? I I have a very personal uh personal take on this.
Uh because I can't believe that Hassan had like I can't believe
the normality with which progressives and liberals talk about
Hassan when I've seen Hassan, you know, like jokingly but then
not jokingly say that America deserved 911. When I've seen him,
you know, make excuses for Hezbollah.
When I've seen Shouldn't that Wait, what if that gets votes though?
What if that were to get him getting office? Yeah. Yeah. My my
line is jihadist terrorism. That that actually is one of the
non-negotiables.
Does Okay. Why? Yeah. I I can answer why. Sure. So, when I when
I was when I was 14, I saw 3,000 people butchered on live television.
The home city in which Hold on. The home city in which I was
born,
uh, the B in Boston that was bombed by jihadist 5-year-olds.
What's that? You think Do you think jihadists watch Hassan in
the modern day? I think that he radicalizes young Americans to
sympathize with jihadists. And what if what if that prevents
fascism from taking over America? Why? What's that? Why is that?
Hold on. Why is that a problem? Do you think do you think most
of America even if even if Assan got them got people to be sympathetic?
Do you think Do you think that like uh most people would be like,
"Oh, 911 was like not a big deal or 911 too is going to be fine."
I I will just I'm not sure what you're asking me. What would
I like pragmatic? Can you tell Connor that is typically used
as an insult? I won't. But you smaller words in shorter sentences.
I'm just saying that like by your logic if Hassan was significantly
more impactful than Destiny. It's just a util argument, right?
Then why how is the negative util of him uh celebrating like
20 guys getting kidnapped, right? Which realistically celebrating
20 guys getting kidnapped minimizing some and what is it? Like
I I think the the kidnapping thing was disgusting to me, but
realistically it's not really like I would probably actually
have more criticism for if he doxed a bunch of his critics and
then said, "I hope somebody rids me of these people. I hope somebody
goes and these people." I actually would probably have more criticism
for that. So I actually don't know how you could say Hassan is
worse than destiny. Uh yeah, it it actually is just like a hard
line with jihadist terrorism. Um so but but here here's the thing.
So here's the thing. Sorry.
Uh, this is one of those things that's so repulsive that I really
wish that there was like a a sensible rightwing. It actually
sucks that there isn't. But I think I have to already before
the midterms, I have to make my piece already with the fact that
people view Hassan differently than I do. And I can't personally
swallow the bitter pill that would be like working with Hassan.
But there are people that I work with who might work with us
on like he's already he's already talked to uh who is it? AOC.
He's already talked to Bernie. I think he's already showed up
to like Bernie rallies. I think that uh there's people who were
in the I went to DC and I went to a meeting. Um I think I and
someone else at the meeting were forwarding the fact that sympathizing
with jihadist terrorism was probably a hard line that we shouldn't
cross. And I think there were some people who thought h you know
maybe may maybe Hassan's social relevance is more important than
a little bit of jihadist sympathy. So there were people definitely
thinking like you were thinking. I just can't think that way.
Okay. Yeah. I just I literally like it seems like Hassan's the
bigger platform and he does less personally disgusting things
like to to the people around him. like Hassan. Hassan maybe the
worst I've ever seen Hassan act to like somebody he's like friends
with is maybe to Ethan which like that is pretty bad but like
he wasn't posting up Ethan's address and saying like actually
Ethan deserves to die. Yeah. To to me Hassan though is uh he's
political rat poison because he's just to me he's the inverse
of MAGA. He's everything that I fought against for I don't know
a half decade before MAGA became relevant. So, so to me, to me
it's kind of like, well, shouldn't you support
anti-MAGA in order to defeat MAGA? And it's like, you know, should
I drink rat poison in order to defeat my cancer? There might
actually be an argument for rat poison defeating cancer, but
you know, I might still be dead. But you understand, you're just
reskinning your argument you made in favor of, well, if he saves
two children, you can rape one. Like, this is just a res I guess
I'm a I'm a rule utilitarian. Jihadist terrorism is worse than
[__] kids. No, Jesse didn't [__] kids,
right? He leaked homemade pine. No, but you said you couldn't
support somebody who who elevates or supports or has sympathized
with jihadist terrorists, but you could accept somebody who raped
one kid for every two he saves. Okay, that was absolutely us
being hyperbolic on WOW or whatever whatever's podcast and they
they were saying like oh yeah so that was absolutely hyperbole
where hyperbole was where was like would you let Jimmy Savile
one kid if it saved 50,000 kids from cancer and it's like yeah
I'm going to bite the bullet because this is a like a raw hypothetical
like yeah but didn't you bring the bullet down you bring the
number down molest what's Uh I thought you brought the number
down to like 10 10 kids saved to one. Well, wait. Like uh what?
Uh and bear in mind we're being hyperbolic. God, we always have
to do the It's a joke. Yeah. Sorry. Uh I do know you're trying
to get your I I understand that if you ever want to be a safe
word if you ever want to come on again. Yeah. Now I have to explain
that like you know a child who get like or whatever you know
that they're still alive so it's not as bad as jihadist terrorism.
Like I have to explain like the differences between the two.
Like no, I think it's sufficient to say that like that we all
have to do a calculus between the evils that we will tolerate
in the world in order to prevent additional evils. We all have
to make that calculation.
And
uh I I don't I don't think I've settled on how allegedly evil
Steven is and how much uh I shouldn't be around him because he's
unrepentant. I I don't think I've decided that yet. Yeah. I I
mean I'm not like pushing you in a direction. I'm mo mostly just
working off of the principles you stated, right? That you needed
contrition. You needed um you you said you would always distance
yourself on, right? I'm just gonna tell you I I've given I've
given up on contrition. I don't think he's capable of it. Yeah,
sure. It's like it's like asking a a dog to ride a unicycle.
It's only going to happen every so often. All right. Okay. Yeah.
I'm trying to think. I might I'll check my document really quick.
Um did you want to take Some people asked to call in. Did you
want to take any callins from people? Not really. It's kind of
late and I got [__] to do. But all right. Um, you
know, just uh for the people who want to call in, just DM me
on Twitter, Discord, and if you're not a then maybe I'll talk
to you. I will say that specifically. And so if it was, would
you make any exceptions or you Yeah. Okay. No, no offense, but
I don't want to talk about the Jimmy Savile ratio to kids to
preventing cancer analogy again. Okay. Uh, let's see here. Um,
I I wrote down like a couple things. One was just Destiny consistently
muddies the water on what action he's responding to hide the
fact responding to to hide the fact that he is not directing
his anger into the right place whatsoever. That's just like when
he says there's lots of people on Jay Doc's discord who do this
he he never is specific and then if he is specific it's like
not something that ties to me except in the one case of Kelly
Jean where then if you're arguing about broad character the discord
where everybody pushes back and I'm pushing back and people have
said oh it's good that you push back like I feel like that's
not the same but yeah in in order for me to take that seriously
uh the Kelly Jean Association or whatever then he wouldn't have
to disavow his 2022 content but he would need to say going forward
forward, why he's not doing it, and how he recognizes it's bad.
So, just as an example, uh I think I think a billion orbiters
came to him in 2022 and they said, "Listen, like Lav's entertaining,
but she's terrible for XYZ ABC reason and she's actually kind
of like destroying the social network." And then people said
the same thing about Max and uh Destiny said, "I don't care.
It's fire content. Who gives a right?" And so if if he's going
to if he's going to criticize you for having Kelly Jean on for
saying wild then he needs to say basically well since 2022 I
realize that I hurt a lot of people despite producing fire content
and therefore I think I have a moral responsibility in who I
platform. That way I don't hurt additional people. Now, the problem
with that is it's hard to say that while you're also saying these
people should be doxed and so but he would have to say that in
order for me to care about that criticism. Okay. All right. Sorry.
Did you have another bullet point? Uh I actually do need to check
my document one more time. That was at the very bottom, but I
think there was some stuff we missed in the middle. Um I think
we we broadly hit all of it, I would say. Um yeah, I don't need
to like I understand that you can change. I don't need to sit
here and like scream that you're a hypocrite. And I I feel like
I didn't do that before. I feel like most of my stuff before
was um arguing on points. I don't think I I think I broadly most
of the time it wasn't until he started like uh threatening docs
and stuff that I was like oh I stopped saying well if you watch
him like I don't care if you just think he's funny and a bad
person like I don't really care. That's your prerogative. And
now that he's like you know doing the doxing and threatening
to saying like you should please people. Now I'm like, "Oh, actually
watching him might actually be a bad like a moral bad. It might
actually be prop into the world." Well, in this this is the may
maybe I've just become like numb to Twitch and YouTube politics
over the past several years. That's probably a that that might
be a problem. The I think it is a viol like a a very strong violation
of YouTube creator norms and etiquette. So just as an example,
I debated Mike from PA. I think you know like two or three years
ago. I think I called him a piece of [__] [__]
dumbass, whatever. But we left it out on the field, right? Like
like we we had our debate. We disliked each other viciously.
We called each other bad names. And then we left. And there was
no efforts on my part or anybody that I'm associated with to
find his personal information in order to make his life miserable.
And as far as I know, there was no effort on his part in order
to come after me. Even though we're actually ideological enemies.
if he had a gun and I had a gun and we were fighting for the
future of the country, we might actually legitimately like smoke
each other, right? So, but the thing is we left it out on the
field because it's better to have these conversations here than
it is to try to ruin each other's personal lives. And so the
fact that Stephen is openly saying, "Yes, I want Queenman's personal
life. Yes, I want JTO's personal life ruined,
uh, or harassed, uh, he needs to have a goddamn fantastic justification
for that, or else he's violating probably one of the biggest
social norms in the Twitch and YouTube political space." And
I I probably should be more alarmed. I I think I think my I think
my brain is just like numb and dead at this point. Well, I also
like I understand and that's why I've tried to be a little more
calm in this conversation because like this was broadly before
this I think most of the time when I had arguments with people
at least on my platform I try to be like understanding. I I know
that um people will disagree with you if they think you're an
[__] right? Even if they think even if they know
you're right, they'll disagree with you, right? So, if I was
sitting here like screaming that you're like a horrible hypocrite,
you won't disavow this guy, I think you'd broadly not be as receptive.
So, I'm just trying to be a little more calm and cool about it.
Um so, I hope that I'll put it under consideration. If anything,
I think you uh you gave me more things that I have to think about
now, which is a pain in the ass, but I guess it's good for you.
Yeah. All right, cool. Well, thanks for coming on. I heard your
I obviously watching I heard your Warhammer channel hit 100K
so you get your little plaque and stuff. That's pretty cool.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, uh ju just just sharing even though we
were talking about uh kids in order to save them with cancer.
Uh good news on my front. So, uh I did break 100k on the Warhammer
channel. I did get my silver play button. It does bring in a
little bit of money. Uh also, I started streaming full-time.
Uh so, I'm doing that in two locations. Uh one of them is my
Counterpoints political channel. There I'll be live from noon
to 5:00 on Tuesday. And then Monday through Friday, all the other
days, I'm live on the Valor Media Network. Uh, and basically
it's
uh, just being transparent, it's it's there's not really like
a political direction to it. It's just broadly anti- athoritarian
uh, anti-MAGA. And then, uh, it's like first responders, veterans,
uh, cops, Navy Seals, all that kind of stuff. They're all starting
a bunch of different podcasts and shows on it in order to try
to be like more positive in the world and then uh Valor is allowing
me to stream uh 20 hours a week on their channel and talk smack
about you know alternative media figures. Okay. Is this um you
might not be able to answer. Is this a part of like your political
project? Like you're getting paid by like uh some pack money,
some political Yeah. Uh believe it or not, it's actually an offshoot
of Midas. Okay. mightest touch. So, I've heard of those guys.
They got they, you know, one or 200 thousand subs, I think, or
one or two million, something like that. I think they I think
they have a few million. I think they're like the most popular
channel on YouTube right now. So, yeah, they're Yeah. So, it's
an it's an offshoot of Midas Touch. Uh they're they're giving
me a shot. I got six months to uh build something. Uh and then
if it's successful and the channels pop in and we got money and
we got revenue and we're doing great, then that'll be my job
going forward. And then if 6 months uh it doesn't work, then
I'll be reporting back to the wage cage. So, we'll we'll we'll
see. But say say a prayer for me. Yeah. No, I mean uh yeah, I
hope I hope this goes well for you. Hope the Warhammer stuff
continues to go well. I know I had fun the one night Yumi and
Really watched uh A Stardies. Good. Yeah, it was good stuff.
It's very fun. It was better with you there though to explain
everything that was going on. So, well, if uh if we ever get
away from obviously like in drama, if it bleeds, it leads. But
if uh if we ever get away from uh drama and we need to revisit
Warhammer, I'll be happy to be your Warhammer Sherpa. Okay. Yeah.
Thank you. All right. Well, sounds good. Yeah. I hope I can have
you on again if you want to talk. I'm covering I think more politics
now. Um we'll see specifically. It's just it seems to be just
seems to be the easier way to go about um filling time when there's
not big drama going on. Reed. What do you mean ask about? Yeah.
Also, I might be going into some true crime or legal stuff. I
think the I think the legal stuff is like uh trying to do a stickick
in like law tube as somebody without a law degree. I think that
would be very funny. Look, I'll I'll predict these cases better
than these guys with chat GPT. I think would broadly be the idea.
I don't know if it would work, but Well, and that that's one
of the things that I found very interesting. And so I would,
you know, obviously talking about Sneo, Andrew Tate, Vosch, uh,
Benny Johnson, Noah Samson, all those people. Um, on stream,
you're, you know, your numbers can bump up when you're, and by
the way, their their release schedule is crazy and their thumbnails
are crazy. I'll I'll be talking to them about it. Don't worry
about it. But the, but the point is that, uh, talking politics
and politics drama obviously can bump your numbers a little bit.
But what's cool about Valor is since it's like
um, I started talking about like a law enforcement shooting and
I started talking about military tech that was coming out and
my my numbers went up when I moved away from the drama and I
was like, "Oo, that's that's cool." So, so I'll still be talking
about politics and drama and alternative media personalities,
but I'll also be talking about police shootings and uh you know,
crime issues and body cameras and military technology. Okay.
Yeah, sounds good. I hope I hope it goes well. I don't know.
I have like no idea. By the way, the thumbnails look pretty on
meta to me. The arrows are like on meta. The arrow is just the
meta. Okay. You don't make a thumbnail without an arrow right
now. That arrow has to be pointing at somebody. Okay. Yeah. My
Okay. my I I'll just say my type in uh go to Midas real quick
though. I was just going to I was just going to show you the
arrow on your latest video. Just look, it's got an arrow. Look,
it's got an The arrow arrows are meta. Okay, I'm trying to get
this guy under control. He's out of this He's out of control.
Okay, but I don't I don't own the channel. I can't actually officially
I I can't even DMCA people on YouTube, okay? They could just
take all my content. There's nothing I can do about it. We go
to Midas real quick. Oh, Midas. M. Oh, yeah. The yellow arrows
on Midas. Yeah, I know. I know about these. Well, so all I was
going to say is I if I had to look at Luke Beasley, Adam Mockler,
Midas Touch, uh even Destiny to an extent Josiah Josiah, this
is this seems like the best thing is your subject
large then large text with a brief summary and then a not necessarily
hyperbolic but an exclamatory or questioning sentence. as a title.
That seems to be what actually ras it in. And so if I was making
a recommendation to anybody who's trying to make it big in like
political commentary,
uh this seems to be the what what all the successful people are
doing. Whereas if you have busy text and too many characters,
it's it's too busy. People don't click on it as much. So I used
to talk with August um Destiny's editor and he was the one who
pointed this trend out to me. And the basic idea is once like
really big channels are doing this and then some smaller channels
start to build up audience based on doing it. It's like everybody
can chameleon in and sort of draft after the after the audience
like draft uh behind that big channel and catch a bunch of their
audience who will be like oh that's a that's this video and then
it won't be that video but it's the video they wanted to watch
cuz they clicked on it right and then they'll sit there and they'll
watch. And that's like broadly I think how Josiah I mean I will
say Josiah is incredibly informed. He puts a ton of work into
his videos and but like aside from that, this is one of the ways
he could draft off of these bigger channels. Ended up uh yeah,
actually you were going to type in counterpoints 40k. Type in
counterpoints 40k real quick. Points 40k. So click on that. Nobody
cares about black talon, which is the last three uh anywhere
near as much. But like raptors, hammer and bolter, a stardis
2. Um I'm trying to think of what else. Uh the secret level was
going to be big no matter what. I could have the thumbnail ever.
But but if you notice the way that we're doing thumbs, sometimes
I would take battle scenes and I would make the battle scenes
the thumbs, but to be honest, they didn't perform as well as
a definitive character. Big subject. Yeah. Big subject. Yeah.
Yeah. So, so the reason why I always have like a face or a mask
or a face and a gun or something like that um is because it seems
like people that that is the best way to get somebody's time
and attention is to have a declarative uh a declarative title
uh mixed with an identifiable subject. And if you don't have
an identifiable subject, if you have too many words on it, um
it's just too busy and people don't click on it as much. Yep.
Yep. Yeah. It's like glancing you aspiring creators out there.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Cool. All right. Anything else you wanted to
bring up or No, that's it. Um if if you guys uh it's not going
to it'll be news then it'll be probably uh breaking down some
alternative media personality and then it'll be military tech
and that kind of stuff. But if you guys are uh whoever's watching,
if you need something to watch um from noon to 5 EST, Monday
through Friday, come check me out on Valor Media and or just
counterpoints my political channel and I'll see you there. Cool.
All right. Thanks for coming on. Have a good one. Talk to you
later. Appreciate you. You too. Good night. Bye. Good night.
Beep. I think Queen might have wanted to hop on here after this
convo. Back into the open channel. Do people want to talk? Want
to chat? Say some stuff. Whoa, that was really fast. Fat guy,
am I right? Right after I was like, "Oh, hey, I'm trying to be
nice to What a piece of What a piece of that guy." I like that
much. Yeah. I don't know. That That went decently. I don't know.
I Yeah, it was into a blood lust at the end when I started hearing
him say, "How terrorism is my red line?" I'm like, "Bro, come
on. The the American 911 thing is like not that bad really. It's
like fine. It's just a point about blowback. You're actually
you are gay if you get upset about that sort of thing. You are
just being a yancoid like a mama. I I thought about going into
that like do you do you think about why Hassan says that when
it's like the point about you know western imperialism up these
countries and them having like a blood debt against the US. Maybe
if people uh listen to that quote a bit closer. Maybe uh you
know they would have more criticism for Israel right now on the
on the merits of you know just their own interests. Interesting
how he brings up 9/11 and Hassan talking about 9/11 for um a
reason we won't associate with him. But but what about uh what
about Pearl Harbor? He's still like, you know, we'll collaborate
with uh what's his face as he's like going to Japan? What about
the USS Liberty? But he's still associated with Destiny while
he's defending Israel. What? What? What is the USS Liberty? I've
never heard of this before. Queen, you heard of the USS Liberty
before? No. This is some strange insane. So like this is only
I feel like this or something like far right. No no no no liberty.
The stickers guy sounds antis actually.
It was an accident but it was still immoral. Okay. People died.
It was an accident. It was an accident. It was an accident. They
accidentally drove up to this boat and then strafed all of the
survivors very accidentally. I don't actually think that happened.
It's just like a random video. I can't remember where we saw
that. Maybe it's on I can't remember where we watched. Somebody
said that in a video recently. We've been watching some weird
[__] Um, yeah. Did you have any thoughts on that
that convo? How it was going? How it went? Dude, that was uh
because I Yes, because I just finished watching the conversation
he had with Destiny the uh the other day. He's not changed his
position at all. At all. Um, and yeah, still getting like talking
points from Destiny. Um, it's like, yeah, I mean I I would he
sat there, he went through the message and he said that he thought
Destiny was wrong. So he he did he said Destiny was wrong, but
he like has he changed his association with him like at all.
Um, to be determined and I to in the debate he had with Destiny
I mean he didn't even really challenge him on it at all like
pointing to somebody's like public only fans. I don't know. It's
just everything he says is so hyperbolic. The way he describes
his own stuff is like, you know, um like the most minimalist
like interpretation you could possibly give while being like
technically maybe like factually correct. And the way he talks
about what everyone else is doing is uh the most hyperbolic stuff.
It's like completely dishonest. Yeah. I think it was just generally
like not when I pointed out the whole Shondaanda Black thing
gave me that point. Um just like like I remember everybody around
Destiny retweeting. I made like some tweets about that and I
could go look. I could actually probably just go find it on my
account and see like all the people who retweeted it and just
look at the ones that are like silent now and like oh well what
can you do? He's he's calling for people's deaths. What can you
do? Right stickers. Did you actually watch that the the whole
conversation you had with Destiny? Even the very very end. Even
the very very end.
Dude, somebody told me about your um your DM to Connor uh when
I first started watching it. Trolling me. I was with him. I literally
didn't expect him to do it. I was just I was just [__]
it. Cuz he was annoying me that he wasn't arguing back at all.
So I was just like, "Well, you gay if you don't do this thing."
Oh, okay. So you're gay then. That's what I said to him in DMs
like you're gay if you don't do this. Like five, oh, so you're
gay then. Like literally stop watching and then yeah, I heard
about this is a reminder, you know, if you ever want Connor to
say something to Destiny live while he's in a debate with him,
just call him gay. Just call him gay. a real do it out of shame.
Oh my god. And and Destiny didn't even deny it, which is like,
oh my god. No, he justified both. He He justified it twice. He
justified it once by himself and he justified it when Connor
was on stream. He's like, no, this is why I did that. Why I called
for their death. Oh yeah, definitely. And then it was like a
non-answer. What's that? Because my signals, but yeah. Oh, sorry.
Sorry. I was just looking at this tweet had 6.6 million views
and 2.2K likes. me being like, "Hey, it's really gay that this
Shondaanda black guy is calling for violence against Destiny."
Apparently, a lot of people cared. See, Icarus Bath was mad about
it. You guys can keep talking, but I'm going to keep scrolling.
Sorry, I was paying attention to Twitter. My bad. No, no, no,
it's right. Oh, look. Yeah,
look, he is there. He is there saying it's bad. What do you want
me to say?
That's basically that that was like
my reasoning for feeling like a I'm like I feel like a for saying
this was bad. And then all of the people who retweeted it, Ro,
they don't give a They're just like, "Yeah, whatever.
You deserved it." Okay. Kelly Jean talked about his girlfriend's,
but you deserve to be doxed and killed now. Oh, look. It's August.
Also, somebody who's like, "Yeah, you probably just deserve to
be killed and doxed." But whatever. That's fine. Well, I don't
I don't think August thinks that. I don't think August thinks
that. Uh, okay. disturbing things I'm hearing about this app
as well. Just a quick reminder, PSA, don't push when you shoot
it. You know, more fiber. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Oh, look. Willy Mack
was really Willy Mack wanted to amplify this one, too. Crazy.
Oh my god, that's really funny, actually. And then fast forward,
what is it? Less than a year. And he's like, actually, would
these guys get death threats? It's like I just think about how
annoying they are actually. Amazing. Maybe, hold on, though.
But maybe Willy Mack's video will be like, "Destiny's actually
insane. Look at how insane he's gone." Did you see that? Um,
Tommy C put out a 30-minute video about the the ye stuff. What
ye stuff? The Willy Mack and us. Dang. Oh, no. But I'm guessing
basically 13 minutes. Yeah. Yeah, it's basically 13 minutes of
just Well, actually, I I hate you. So, it's basically getting
death threats. That's like the whole 13 minutes. It's like, okay,
fair enough. But it's not particularly compelling. I can't be
real. Yeah. I just I as we go through time, I'm just more and
more blackpilled. Like literally, listen, it's some people here.
This guy, if this guy said that we're we're like we're we're
losers, so it's okay to kill us. I I'd be like, "Okay, you're
consistent. You thought it was bass when Shawn Black did it.
You think it's bass when when uh when Destiny does it? That's
consistent." I don't care when Shauna Black did it. I don't care
when Destiny does it. I think it's gay as a hypocrisy, to be
honest. So, just say you don't care. I never cared. It was kind
of funny actually to be honest. Wait. Um, what did he say? He
said this what happens when you every slave owner. Was that it?
Uh, this what happens when you he said somebody would destiny
and like then socialism would prosper in America. Slave owner
thing. Just go and just says the n word. Okay. Which is not a
surprise.
Every slave owner after slavery they have kids and their kids
become destiny. Yeah, it was like the same string. That part
that part was funny. That part was funny. That that they're so
gay. That part was funny. Did Connor address Destiny leaking
the name of Lauren Southern's kid to a Discord holder?
Uh, listen, she's just a worker. Don't call her Discord. Discord
kitten, please use the proper name. Uh, no, but I talked about
it in DMs. I can't remember. He didn't really He was like, "Oh,
that's what happens when I He kind of committed in that direction.
He was like, I guess shouldn't shouldn't share things with Destiny.
What can you do?" Um, let's see here. What did you think about
Destiny? Uh, sorry about Connor referring to the whole Dachshun
thing as a as a breach of etiquette, like a kind of a, you know,
kind of a a social faux part. It's a breach of etiquette. Oh,
I mean, he started going back to like, no, it's actually really
bad. No, it's actually really bad. As I continue to sort of explain
sort of like Destiny's standard for being allowed to dox and
send death threats towards people or say you want people to kill
them was like essentially nothing. no proof, no nothing. And
if you like accept that standard, then what would prevent it
from coming at you? Uh I also asked him like basically like what
would you do if this guy flipped on you too? Like basic it seems
like it's just people who like turned against him and the wicked
by asking that question that that I sent him. He's literally
already created the grounds for Destiny to flip on at any time.
Destiny could literally start going down in full force and he
it's already justified like he just etiquette to downplay the
breach. I don't know. I don't get too hung up on people's words.
Like I But that's just me. I don't know. Maybe I'm just I just
don't care when people use the etiquette or when ye tweeted like,
"Oh, this is a spicy thing." Just doesn't bother me. I guess
it it bothers some people. I never It's It depends. Maybe if
it's like against me, I don't care. I I do notice it when it's
against other people, I guess. So, sorry answering a chat message
there. Yeah, he broadly just gave Oh, and Erdite, too. And it's
like realistically, how do I know that you and Erdite aren't
supporting him because you guys just don't want to get I don't
know. I like at some point I don't know like are are the people
even supporting him just like terrified of this guy or maybe
not maybe in denial about being terrified of the guy, right?
Like well I guess I made my bed. Guess I made my bed. Guess I
have to stay here now. I I think the thing I've I've said I think
a couple of times is like Connor's trying to like start streaming
regularly. He's kind of starting to rely on this for like a job.
Um a lot of the other people he has like connects with don't
really like him. Uh especially after like the PV stuff, the association
with Brianna Woo. Now, the Destiny stuff, he could try and move
away from Destiny, but he's never gonna like explicitly uh like
condemn him. And he he probably needs that kind of like connect
for growth. Like he's coming on like my live stream with like
80 viewers and trying to like say, "By the way, by the way, I'm
going to be streaming soon. By the way, by the way, I'm going
to be, you know, this time to this time I'm going to be streaming."
He'll go on any he'll go on anyone's stream anyway. So, he Yeah.
And he literally said on my stream, he was like, "Yeah, I just
because people were open with me, like even bigger creators like
Destiny and Bosch that like I try to extend that to everybody
even though like I'm like he he wasn't even trying to say he
was bigger than me. He was just like I just try to make sure
if people ask me for a combo and I have time, I do it. Yeah.
Yeah. Like I'd say that's probably No. No. Yeah. I don't know
if it's mostly about growth and he will shut him shut himself
out, but I think that's usually he probably just assumes he's
got that like right by hopping on your stream for free, right?
No, that's fair. That is fair. No, I'm not bemmoning him for
that at all. I was just think I was just saying that um I think
he's probably keeping the the Destiny connect for um
kind of growth or viewership or you know to get more follows
and stuff. Yeah. Um and like I I just think if I had to guess
I would think that probably a lot of this is more about Arrodite
than it is Destiny to be honest him being friends with Ardite.
I think Erodite has some ultra negative opinions of me and Queen.
Um I don't think she's advocating for this by the way. I'm saying
that like probably a lot of Destiny's actions are based on Erdite
feeling really bad about getting criticized and like um people
being unhinged towards her and probably a lot of Connor's actions
are also based on that. I think they just have like a fairly
warped perception based on them believing Erdite's like a a victim.
I don't know. That's that's my mind readad of the situation.
Maybe that's totally unfair, but I think that's probably like
he's probably sticking by Destiny because he wants to stick by
Aerudite and that's to to be honest that's like that seems to
be more what it is. I don't know if he really they considered
not encouraging their mentally disabled friend to do politics.
That seems cruel to me. That's I I I would never argue that Erd
like deserves it, right? But um like at least not uh like I think
she has been I think she's had PII revealed and I I don't know
if she's been swatted, but it wouldn't shock me. Like I think
like she's probably in the same situation that Queen and I are
in terms of feeling like under threat. And maybe you could try
to say, "Well, by watching her content and reacting to it and
being like rude, you're continuing that, but then I don't know
how you justify any of the content in this entire space for the
past 5 years." Yeah. Conor I think Connor would say that's just
the game, right? He he would probably say my coverage is the
game. Yeah. Well, I think so. Like you put out public messaging
and you put up public statements. I think you should just be
able to mostly like I I don't I've never gotten mad about people
reacting to my except that one time Nicholas reacted to it and
then refused to talk to me. That was annoying as actually he
agreed to talk to me and you're not mad about the reaction. You're
mad about my mate. Yeah. Although I do I I remember when Nicholas
used to come in the Discord and hang out. Never again. I guess
we had to be divas. Oh, because because you were a diva. Not
me. You You were a diva. I I I Yeah, I don't even I By the way,
I also like let the whole Willie Mac thing go. He was like seething
on Twitter for like two weeks after that and he was like talking
[__] about me, random replies. I was just like, "You
know what? I won't I won't say anything." I think I made a comment
in spicy chat that one guy got uh angry about, but that was it.
It was really over the Willie Mac stuff. Yep. I I didn't think
he got himself that that involved in um in the in the Willy Mack
conversation at the time. Uh no, he got fairly involved, but
I think it was mostly just protecting a friend. You deserted
the forever war against Willie. No, I said I said if there was
going to be a war, I'd fight, but I was just like I just wanted
it to die because I wanted to focus on covering some Destiny
stuff, you know, as that developed. By the way, you guys, um,
feel free to talk or jump in whenever you want. I'm like I had
like two hours of sleep. So, I I did not my brain my brain worked
for about an hour and a half talking to Connor and now it's it's
over. Holy moly. Um, we have a bigger fish to cook. Well, we
did back then. Now it's like now I'd much rather talk to Willie
about stuff. I'd tell Willie to hop on the stream, too. Maybe
Willie would hop on the stream and just like squash the beef.
Here, you know what? I'm I'm gonna send Willie a message right
now. I get the feeling that Willy's uh stream uh stream guest
appearances might be over for a little while. I'm not sure. Hey,
you never know. I messaged him. Any chance he'd want to hop on
stream and squash the beef? Hey, I messaged him. What do you
mean by squash the beef? What? You wanna You want to argue? Oh,
you just said I'm so annoying that he doesn't care that I'm getting
death threats. So, I mean, like, there must be some beef there.
No. Wow. I think I think this is another aspect of um what do
you call it? I think this is an whole play this right now. Oh
god, did I what did I say into a thing and Queen's on one side.
I'm on Queen's side. Okay, that guy I'm on his side. So I don't
need anything. If you guys can't squash that yourselves, I will
eventually once we're past this be on whatever side he's on.
Okay, I'm just saying it. Just letting you know. Yeah, that's
um that that was my position was like, hey, if you guys are like
going to go after Queen or something, I will absolutely participate,
but if it just dies down, that's better. Yeah. Uh, I I would
just say like whatever is leading to you like having the hatred
going on. Uh, if he wants to squash that beef